ready to do this thing my little brother
the soldier of death I like it this show
is presented by on
it but days are back everyone the Church
of What's Happening Now is proud and
honored to introduce you to
hellotushy.com
hellotushy.com makes portable devices
that spray your butt your tushy clean
with water go to hellotushy.com church
right now to get 10% off of your order
that's hellotushy.com
last Church nobody wants to have a
stinky Muffler during the holidays you
understand me no one does the show is
also brought to you by hint water hint
water is pure water infused with a fresh
Taste of fruit with the taste of fresh
fruit excuse me and the best part is our
listeners get a single variety pack ship
variety pack shipped directly to your
door including three bottles of their
four most popular flavors for only $15
that's drink hint.com church
drinkhint.com church I'm drinking some
apple as we speak and it's
delicious oh
[__] you wanted it you got it
[__] Uncle Joey
here yes but as a known scientist it a
bit surprising if a girl blinding me
with my little Goomba Le sayat
the princess of Jersey Vicky pezza
yo here we go taking your
back taking you back [__] here
you go get the bikini
on oh [__] break out the cocoa
butter here we go it's
over break out the Gorilla Biscuits
we're going
deep
Wednesday 16th of
[Music]
November
[__] oh [__] here you
go going to take it murky Waters right
now if you're driving wiggle that
[__] ass [__] y out the show
dance this mother here we
go oh
[__] take this one science science
damn uh uh uh uh uh I
[Music]
machy the Church of What's Happening Now
[__] CU it's happened Wednesday night
you're here I'm here everybody's healthy
half the week is over Clinton is dead
Trump is bullshitting you and it don't
matter cuz Uncle Joey is here to save
the day with his trusted little [__]
Jewish [__] velvet hammer and the
princess of New Jersey Vicky pezza
welcome to the show Vicky pezza thanks
for having me guys [__] still here
you've been here since day one with us
we chitchat on the phone now you're
working on a whole different podcast yes
one that
face they laugh they giggle everybody's
happy and [__] Lis what's up with you
[__] oh my God I'm doing good I'm
enjoying this chocolate I had a I'm
having a a fun weekend ahead of me I'm
excited what are you doing this weekend
I'm going to Pismo Beach because uh
Paula is getting her bar results so oh
my God we go here we go we'll see what
happens here we go I wonder there was
going to get [__] food poisoned this
week did you get a food pack what did
you do already there's no I always
something there's always something he
comes back with [__] red eye or a
stain on his head like the [__]
ex-president of Russia last time he went
away when they came back with a [__]
thing on his head and he didn't even
know it he's walking around with a patch
of [__] fungi on his head oh my God
from the jacuzzi oh it was the jacuzzi
it was airbnb's fault so this time I'm
staying in a hotel thank [__] God now
you can blame it on the mate Esther you
to worry about [__] Airbnb Esther
didn't clean the toilet I got a red rash
between my legs and [__]
luckily you won't see that thank God n
those [__] I like listen man I like
hotels yeah I have to traveling so long
I really do like hotels I don't know why
I just feel safer I feel better I feel
cleaner you know I always bring flip
flops and [__] to protect yourself cuz
you know these people are animals what's
the deal with airbnbs it's like you're
staying at someone's house essentially
is that yeah pretty much
idea I don't think so not for me it's
not for me no and I don't want nobody
staying in my [__] house either like
renting a room to some guy 60 a night I
don't know what he's doing in there I
don't know what the [__] you're doing in
there I don't know you that's the
creepiest [__] thing in the world
yeah you know it seems like instead of
watching out we're giving more trust
it's like um Uber for example okay Uber
or any car service you know I was
talking to a cab driver cuz I always
take a cab back from Burbank Airport I
feel bad for those guys they sit out
there from 6 in the [__] morning and
youngsters are taking Ubers right in
front of me you go to bird B cport
there's 15 [__] Ubers there yeah you
know and and the cab driv are [__]
livid yeah they're livid you know so I
was talking to him one then he was
explaining to me how Uber if you get
into a car accident with an Uber and you
suit them you only get like [__]
5,000 bucks like damages and [__]
because a cab is ured to a half a
million dollars there was some big
difference he goes that's what the
consumer doesn't know right that if
something happens in the [__] Uber
you get a guts yeah cuz you're suing the
person this driver not a a cab company
that has this like Fleet of taxis and
insurance it's kind of weird they were
explain to me and that's why we as a
society it's like okay so things are bad
in your home and uh you're with your
husband and I live at the house and you
things are rough for you know for Vicky
PE so you want to rent out the room
that's okay now do you have a choice who
comes to your home yeah you can deny it
and actually people get in trouble
they're saying like black people aren't
getting accepted as much like I saw I
just saw that with Uber the other day
and it makes sense but like i' I've only
done the Airbnb where I take over
someone's house they have them where you
can just like you're saying have like a
see that's what I I wouldn't mind doing
that just taking over somebody's house
for 4 days that's one thing with them
not in it yeah you know uh in uh in ' 85
I had you know I got into some trouble
and stuff like that I needed a place to
stay and I had slept on people's couches
and that's [__] creepy yeah no matter
how much you like me Vicki your husband
likes me after three nights it's creepy
you know it's like he's living here now
that means in the middle of night you
come out for a glass of water naked you
know I'm sleeping on your couch you got
to dress up to pee it's just so many
inconveniences you know I'm a good house
guest so if I stay on your couch I fold
the sheets I get out of there by nine
right you know but uh it was creepy it
was creepy even though the people love
me and I love them it was still there
was still one point that nobody feels
comfortable yeah you know there really
is I don't care if it's your mother I
don't care a couple years ago a friend
of mine called me and he's like I'm
going to bind for three days I go sure
and I tell you what it pissed me off
because I thought she being a she would
get up in the morning and wash a [__]
and get the the [__] out of the house no
no no no she was one of those game show
chicks game show chicks yeah so me and
my wife would leave and we come back and
it was game shows when we left then the
afternoon it was [__] the black chick
that doesn't know who the who the father
is for the baby my myy and then then but
she was really into like the celebrity
thing and I knew her I know her for 40
[__] years but you don't know
somebody that well like I knew her
growing up and uh you know you come back
and in the afternoon there was still
blankets on the
couch gotcha that's kind of [__]
weird so I know the feeling from both
ends right I I always help somebody in
need you know what I'm saying but the
point of the story is it's so weird I
had a stay I rented a room once in a
house where she was a mom her husband
died and the kids all moved out so the
kids were like Ma you don't want to be
lonely rent out rooms by the month and I
got to tell you something that was a
horrible you weren't allowed in the
kitchen you weren't allowed in theed
basement you weren't allow basically you
were allowed to open the front door and
walk right up the stairs and she would
be sitting on the couch at nights and
I'd be walking and tuned up to the gills
and she'd be cuz she couldn't sleep till
all my boys were in she only rented to
men and she wasn't creepy or nothing and
she would go out she had a job in the
daytime it was just uh I don't know I
just never like how many of you were
there how many three three there was
three me and another Cuban guy upstairs
and downstairs she rented to somebody
she had like a the sons put like a
basement apartment together right right
and you had a sign like it was a
month-to-month lease she didn't want
nobody there longer than 3 months it was
kind of weird I lasted like three
[__] weeks I was there when day her
son came and he was a Coke fiend like me
and we started smoking pot and he's
telling me about his cop spots and my
cop spots and the kid says to me listen
man let's just go over to the city I I
got to go over there anywhere at 5: you
just going to drop me off right he goes
yeah it's cool we go over there on the
way there we go get weed we get some
blow we get high and he says to me you
know where I get rid of this bracelet
and I go whose bracelet is and he's like
oh my I had a girlfriend we broke up I
took the [__] bracelet I go what are
you looking for it he goes I'll take 50
bucks I like $65 I gave the 50 bucks I
walked down two corners sold it I got
like 400 for the [__] bracelet gold
was
High 3 days later the cops coming to
arrest me the bracelet was stolen
robbery oh my God so I got possession of
a stolen property and they took me to
jail they weren't going to they charged
me with something small but [__] uh I
had a warrant out in [__] Edge in
Fort Lee or something CLI side so they
you actually went to a place where like
they took down your address I just asse
D I thought this place now listen I
always dealt with people in Harlem where
you give them a little wink and that
means
melted that doesn't mean [__] look at
the serial numbers and [__] bring it
in report it when you sell gold in those
days it was like four pieces of paper
two of them went to the police
department some places just gave you one
you sign they give you cash everybody's
happy and you move I had a guy that I
used to give him bulk I had a guy I grew
up with that turned me on to another guy
that whenever I had bulk no question
bulk jewelry that's a weird I go to your
house three three [__] Rings six
bracelets uh your Dad wears watches I
show up I get [__] $10,000 for
[__] uh a bat a little [__] one
time I brought him so much [__] he I he
didn't have enough cash he would always
tell you listen if you come here it's
always 10 10K you got to give me 10
minutes to go get it like nothing's
going to be over 10K unless my partner's
here that's the first time that like I
had dealt with him a lot but one time I
showed up and he gave me like 10 and he
goes it's a Friday would you take a
check I'm like [__] drop it on me cuz
I'm not leaving here without my money
right and he never ratted me out like I
had people would just melt the gold they
know what is they know what it is right
this [__] hump in Harlem and like
like a like it was like a shady uh place
the boot that's really [__] killed me
yeah I didn't imagine you went to K's
Jewelers or something like it seemed
like if you going to go sell jewelry now
is that what all those Cash for Gold
places are but just dressed up now is
that like do you think that's where like
junk yeah you come in all right it's a
pawn Lee you come in I look at it I
weigh it gold is high right now correct
it's a th000 an ounce is it Le can you
look up I don't I don't know what the
price is of gold right
now but when I was thiefing and doing my
thing in the 80s it was
900 wasn't bad you can make a little
living [__] thiefing and bringing
back [__] you know oh my God you catch a
good you know the thing was with gold
that you get confused is how they rob
you what's the price of gold for gram an
or an ounce ounce $1,200 yeah wow you're
making paper now you rob
somebody holy [__] but see like if you
rob your wedding band that's that's
douchy to you because the diamond goes
to waste they never really pay you for
diamonds they give you like an exact
amento on a diamond even though your
husband paid 35,000 for the diamond if
it's not perfect they start and when you
go to sell a diamond there's always
flaws when you go to buy it it's [__]
the best thing they've ever seen yeah
this is one of the best listen three
black dudes died off a cliff getting
this
you know and they held it in their hand
till they it didn't even hit the dirt
and [__] uh hands were chopped off
hands chopped off and the whole [__]
thing but when you go to sell it all
they start finding all these floors
there's a little floor on the left side
of the diamond so even if they can get a
th000 for the diamond and they know it
they'll give you a 100 and they'll talk
you down to 100 unless you want to wait
three they'll say it'll take three hours
to mount the diamond off and then
they'll break it it breaks that's why
you never want to Mount the [__]
Diamond cuz it breaks there's so many
little things with jewelry so what
you're looking for are big Rings grad
even college rings like we used to go in
a house four [__] college rings you
got [__] three grand you know what
I'm saying boa boa you always hear about
like NFL players and college players
losing championship rings did you ever
come across one of those Never Never So
to get back to your question you come to
me inside the thing your mom gave you a
gold chain for [__] Christmas last
year you can't make rent I weigh it it's
1,200 an ounce it's a [__] ounce Lee
no matter how you cut I got 1,200 for
you I'm going to give you
six you're going to take the six cuz
you're a Desperado but guess what when
you come back you got to pay me
12 cuz that's the price of gold that's
how they get you I don't know if that's
the scam they're running but there's got
to be some profit when you come back
it's like a por shop you give me a ring
I give you uh 300 for 90 days after 90
days you could come in and start making
me payments and it's like a it's like a
loan it's like a vig and if it but what
if and if it sells within that 90 days
what happens it's not going to sell he
puts in a vault for 90 days and you have
a loan oh okay got it and then he
charges you they either charge you two
ways let's say they give you
300 they charge you whatever $15 a week
plus the
300 until so when you come back let's
say you come back 6 weeks later that you
got to give them let's say it's $30 a
week you got to give them 120 that's how
they make that Profit just like a lone
shark only with you go to who brings
their drums to get ped you go to [__]
por shop they got Drums guitars that
that's why I never got into the guitar
what I'm picturing yeah that's why I
never got into the guitar I would have S
snorted I would have snorted every
[__] guitar I ever
had that's why how that's how they get
you so how do pawn shops work then I
thought like if you brought it in that
they would try to that they'd sell it so
they do they only sell that's
Consignment oh that's a consignment shop
well no so a porn shop is when you come
in and go listen you see that black
crack ho I want to go do crack with what
can I get for this [__] ring and they
take this ring and they wear and he goes
what do you want to do sell it or PA it
they let me PA it for 90 days maybe my
luck will change so let's say you have
this ring is worth 850 they'll give me
325 but for me to get the bring back it
would cost me 10 points a week so that's
3250 so I have 90 days to pay a flat fee
there like a flat fee and then after
that you pay on juice you come in and go
what if I pay juice every week until so
I don't lose
it and then if they lose it then they
can sell it then if if you don't pay it
then I can sell it you can buy it back
but you're going to have to buy it back
at retail
right [__] just like any other customer
just like any other [__] customer jez
so every time that's why I don't like
buying [__] at por shops because it's
bad luck somebody sold it who was down
on their [__] luck do you want to
give me a wedding ring from a [__]
point shop now I got this death finger
on me and [__] I got somebody's [__]
maluk on me now and [__] I got I got to
go home and kill 10 chickens and get
fish eyeballs and rub them on my neck
and then do a Jew thing I got to do
10,000 religions to get that [__]
kiss of De off me I hadn't been in one
and then Paula and I were somewhere and
we just stopped I was I was like I've
never been in a pawn shop let's go in
and it looked like it hadn't been
changed since like the 80s that's all it
is it's just a room oh my god with
accessories anything from cameras to
films to it's [__] creepy and you
look at this stuff and you're like where
do you get this [__] from but I watched
that show sometimes that's a very
interesting show I've learned a lot of
[__] and listen it's not like you watch
it when you're on the road Vicky you put
it on you write you have YouTube on you
listen to music but people bring them
interesting [__] I was watching it last
week when the Green Bay Packers
won couple years
ago every player gets a thing but the
starter wives get something really did
you know that something like that
and they had a pen and they brought the
pen in and the guy goes yeah this is
official they called the NFL straight up
but then they found out that like the
quarterback's wife the MVP's wife gets
one with like a diamond on something
[__] just only you know crazy [__]
that you think is nothing and that's how
they find Value in things that's a very
interesting show like Shark Tank you'll
like Pawn Wars porn whatever with that
company Pawn Stars I've seen it yeah
people come in and bring the weirdest
[__] things and those guys find Value
basically you're a lone shark yeah
you're a legal loone shark truck with
with something in the middle there
what's that it's like uh what were you
oh lay away no no no we were talking
about the thing how you can't sell it so
you'll just get $ donations on PayPal oh
right right right like that just stands
in the way like a bowling ball stands in
the way you go to por there's a bowling
ball you're like who the [__] pored that
bowling ball like what can you get for a
[__] bowling ball like
$7 s [__] dollars for a bowling ball
Jesus
I got it must be huge in Vegas like on
casinos don't you think huge that's why
they're all over the [__] place
[__] why do you think they're all over
the place and they'll buy a wedding band
quick because they'll sell a wedding
band quick holy [__] okay so we're in
Vegas we're drunk you can't lose I'm
drunk you're drunk let's go get married
hold on we got to stop and get a wing at
a at a [__] porn shop go to a porn
shop get a ring for 250 put it on the
Visa
[__] it oh my God yeah it's a no lose
situation porn shops have been I don't
know how they make money like I really
don't know you have to do high volume
like it would be a because some of them
they're in retail spaces and and there's
a lot of rent so yeah yeah I've always
wondered I used to live by one and I
went in there a couple times I remember
one times I found the ring and I went in
there and dropped it
off and
uh how much did he take for it $34 or
something it was like a rusty ring I
found and it was really gold it was
something happened to the outside of it
but the inside had like 10K and I saved
it for like a [__] year and one day I
go what the [__] I need a bag of weed I
walked over I got like I never forget I
got 34 bucks perfect I was looking for
like 50 but I got 34 that's a gram an
edible and a $2 tip $4 tip who gives a
[__] everybody's happy you a anything
Vicky PE no no I never pawned
anything um I the whole concept of it's
like so crazy to me I know I do know
that uh at one point I was told a story
in my family that my grandmother pawned
her wedding ring um but ended up getting
it back so I never knew how that would
work so what you explained kind of kind
of makes sense yeah it's 90 days you're
not really giving it away right it's a
[__]
loan you know it's a loan like I don't
understand the payday loan oh that's
even sad like I think it's the same
thing I think it's the same thing as
like cashing a CH they [__] bang you
out like I was thinking about I I was
driving and I saw checks 1 and a half%
like the place on uh witset uh not
witset it's on Hollywood Boulevard
everybody's cast one check there there's
a there's a street on Hollywood
Boulevard that uh it's like
uh Whitley Whitley and and Whitley and
[__] Hollywood Boulevard I had an
account there you know when I was a
Desperado I had an account there right
you go in you show them your ID you give
them a fingerprint and they'll work with
you on anything they're really [__]
cool and I was I had that was my bank
from
98 to
2007 and I remember like getting the
first big residual check from Spider-Man
and like tell them like the day before
like listen how much money you got in
there cuz I'm coming with a big one for
you tomorrow cuz I you know I was
snorting coke during Spiderman too you
give me a [__] residual check [__] so
here's the problem if I got a check in
those
days like for [__] whatever $1,000 I
got tell my wife it was 800 I rip up the
stub and just tell her 800 and give her
like three or five and keep three and
snort it you know what I'm saying I know
exactly if I had to cash it through her
she knew the exact amount that I was
getting I was
[__] here's a shady thing I she's my
girlfriend you know um now cuz now I'm
thinking about it now that you mentioned
that um what I would do sometimes is
like when I was in college like around
that age like you go out to dinner with
a bunch of people like it's a bunch of
people out to dinner so I would I would
charge the bill on a credit card and I
would take everyone's cash and then you
use that cash to like buy coke right
yeah yeah yeah there's always a scam and
then all of a sudden I have this huge
credit card bill because really I I've
just been like using that to get cash
off of everybody and it's like oh [__] I
still have to pay this credit C can you
still go to a bar can I come up to your
Vicky PE and go I love can I ask you a
question uh give me the bill for me and
my friend but do me a favor give me a
100 back keep 20 for
yourself so once you give me the bill
let's say it's $84 [__] dollars right
I'm going to give you a $20 tip right
whatever $84 is it's uh $840 and $840 is
1680 so I'm going to throw you a 20 and
I'm going to go listen do me a favor add
a 100 to that bill give me a 100 out of
the register and I'm going to give you
20 cash back do people still do that
scam oh I don't know it's not a scam
it's just real you know sometimes I'm at
a bond I'm light money and put add an
extra 100 to this it's kind of [__] up
it's on the borderline of illegal I I'm
not sure I don't think servers
understand that anymore no I remember my
dad used to do that my dad he used to do
it because when he worked at a
restaurant they would give him free
meals but he wanted to tip so he say
open this up for a penny or whatever but
yeah but now I'm I started talking your
accent now everyone like whenever I go
to a restaurant they can't even handle
splitting a check and it's on a computer
it's like it's easiest it couldn't be
easier and people can't even handle
splitting a check so I don't think
anyone's going to be able to like if you
went there and asked put a 100 bucks on
this they'd probably be like what I'm
going to get fired in the mid 80s they
used to get stolen credit cards
I had a friend of mine who would just
hand them over
fresh fresh with an amount and you he
you had to wait till the consumer Ed the
card twice called in then they opened
the account in those days there were
banks that they were K people were so
kinky that when Vicky pezza got a card
they printed two cards one went to Vicky
pezza and one went to me so if they
printed 10 cards a day I got 10 cards
and I had 10 dudes who go out and work
the cards right and I get 10% of their
action this is a real [__] thing to
be really effective with that you have
to go into a different area so if you
live in Jersey and I get the bank out of
New York you have to go like Michigan
yeah so you would drive to Michigan go
to a mall and go crazy in those days the
computer in the 80s when I was doing the
credit cards the computers were so slow
in those days that even if Vicky pezza
called and said hi it's 700 p.m in
California I just realized somebody
stole my card they'd freeze it but it
would only be in that time
zone this is how slow how long we've
come how you feeling over there doctor
I'm feeling better about a minute [__]
up right so you could in those days you
I'd take Vicky pez's card and I'd
overnight mail it to Lee in California
Lee would have two days to use that
card before California would get hit
this is how crazy this is the things you
learn when you're out there like you
guys were too young under $50 up to
like1 1990 if you didn't charge $50 you
could just sign there was no swiper they
put it in the thing and went and ripped
the receipt and gave it back to you so
you would call remember that I remember
called an under the limit Thief people
made a living being under the limit
thieves because I go Vicky what do you
need today I need three underwear from
Marie et okay how much 50 40 bucks no
problem I'll go get you the underway you
give me 20 and then I go get Chinese
lunch and I buy you and Lead lunch right
cuz it's $5 for the lunch so even with
tip it's [__] 22 25 it was called
under the limit living you wouldn't
charge and because and you have to go
and people are busy every great [__]
Moon see in those days American Express
Diner Club MasterCard and Visa sent out
a booklet every
weekly okay every week every [__]
month day when you went to work you had
to take four booklets Diner club and
throw it away and get four more booklets
okay so let's say we're [__]
Starbucks and I come in and I go all
right let me get a coffee for Lee
[__] uh Vicky give Lenny two drinks
he's going to need him get the dog a
drink give the guy that [__] Momo
sitting there and drink and they came
out to $35
right even if she's a [__] Gentile
like somebody who lives by the book like
really believe Batman and [__] like that
those are the only morons that would
stop and open up that booklet with a
magnifying glass cuz that's how small
the [__] numbers were even the VIS
even the credit card companies didn't
want you to know if the card was stolen
because they get insurance on that a so
the numbers would be like so you had to
stop I had I got a line from here to
[__] Lish him you got to stop to get
a magnifying glass to look at this
number and look at the card 3441 this
card is a stolen card nobody ever
[__] did that in the 5 years I was
doing it nobody if it didn't hit 50
bucks you got it that meant socks
sneakers a pair of jeans two tickets to
the movies and i' had four or five
different cards on me I'd be working for
four or five different [__] angles it
was it was [__]
insane and I thought everybody was in
like everybody had a card and a card in
those days I didn't even have a credit
card then it wasn't even in my [__]
realm I didn't even know where to start
to get a [__] credit card and uh I
had like a credit card with two
different names on
them I never used cash in those days for
like two years I was living like a
doctor and you never got caught cuz
that's what I was worried about I got
caught
twice one time I got caught by mistake
my
ex-wife got nailed in San Francisco and
when they asked her what her name was
the dumb [__] was from Denver her name
was Barbara Kors and she spelled it with
a K and the guy goes you spelled your
name wrong and she goes I'm having a bad
day he goes I don't know how I've had
many bad days I always remember how to
write my name I've had a bad day had to
run out of Market Street run down the
street like [__] then one
time the like I would do it like on a
daily there was like a year or two where
I had this friend that I had met by
mistake through a friend to a friend
it's not like I even grew up with him
and he's the one that told me about this
scam but he goes you got to keep it
[__] quiet because he so it was
really when I really went to effect with
it was when I left North Bergen when the
people were looking for me and I ow a
bunch of money I went to crale New
Jersey and I hid in creskill New Jersey
and that's when I really became good
with it he goes don't use it in your
neighborhood right don't use it on the
buses use it in the city in the city
nobody looks at your face and nobody
[__] gives a [__]
and I I became addicted to it like I
became addicted to it CU it's like
unlimited everything you want unlimited
everything and then he started saying
can you get rid of Travelers
checks and those were easy because you
just had to write it out again one out
of 10 people asked you for an ID in
those days you bumped into one [__]
that was you know really believed in the
law and [__] right that said can I get
identification with that and in touristy
places you could go nuts you spend
listen you spending $20 on a $9.99
t-shirt they know it you know it you're
robbing me I'm robbing you give me the
[__] t-shirt and shut the [__] up
you're going to get the 20 for the
[__] t-shirt from the MX people it
was such a it was such a [__] rampid
going on like and I didn't know people
until I met this guy and I would
basically talk to him on the phone from
Jersey go to Harlem pick up weed and I'd
meet him like in lower Manhattan and
we'd meet like by uh 59th and Broadway
and there used to be like a little bar
in there and we talk for an hour and
he'd bring people with him that this is
what they did for a [__]
living they had like you know how people
what's that thing that you get a
somebody and I sell you
soap we we all signed up for that
[__] comp Amway this was Amway for
[__] credit cards like this guy had
50 guys and Brooklyn and the Bronx
working with credit cards that he would
refuel them with three or four credit
cards every three days and these guys
job was to go out and get merchandise so
I come to you and go Vicky P you want to
design a nice studio right you want
microphones that are nice listen these
go for a th000 a piece this this this
you want the computer the speakers it's
10g retail I come back here tonight you
give me five grand cash [__] yeah I'll
give you five grand cash for brand new
[__] in boxes with warranties what do
you give a Frenchman's [__] well now you
can't use the warranty with computers
now they'll definitely catch you with
the stolen merch well even I mean even
the stores uh back when when you're
talking about like would they even have
cameras or the capability to record 247
no mean no no no no they're watching
everything everyone does would be the
only way you could credit quad frud
today is online oh yeah but you have the
problem with online is that you have to
set up different I because I was
thinking about it you know I'm a [__]
criminal no matter what some nights I
smoke a joint I think about Poseidon
some nights I smoke a joint I think
about [__]
how somebody would do this stuff cuz I
absolutely don't know I would have to
get somebody like Lee and like a forer
those [__] like I know there's
Armenians in Glendale that know how to
get 200 credit cards off the computer in
10 seconds and just start buying [__]
and sending it to warehouses where they
don't have to sign for it that just get
dropped off and pray to God I think
that's how you would do it I don't know
I don't know I don't know because you
still got to deliver it right so all
they got to do is wait for whoever signs
and you arrest them at yeah at some
point you have to go pick up this
merchandise somewhere somewhere so
that's the only way I can think of doing
but on a face to face no more at Sears
or at uh I went to the mall tonight uh
what's the name of the [__] dump
anything any more Macy's yeah like even
Macy's no [__] way you use your
credit card you get away with it they're
going to find you nowadays I think the
odds are against you because that's what
I feel I feel because you can't buy that
with [__] glasses and a funny [__]
nose everyone's had they're like I've
had my credit card stolen yeah but look
where they use it and how they use it I
guarantee they used it online uh a
couple a couple times they actually do
try to do it in the storees still they
still do try but I don't think anyone
ever looks for them do you I don't think
well I think when you walk in the store
you have to see if the cameras are
active I think the only way I would use
a card today is If Vicky pezza worked at
someplace and I would go in there and
she'd go listen the cameras are off from
10:00 to 11:00 buy up some [__] inside
jobs I grew up with a friend of mine
that ended up being my first daughter's
godmother and she was a badass [__]
this [__] was a jersey badass [__] and
she worked
at Lord and Taylor and and David yeah
the shoe
place and her and I were goomas I knew
her boyfriend I knew her mother I knew
her father and her and I would sit on
the porch and smoke a joint and this is
before I started doing business she was
telling me her scam how when shipment
comes in you take a pair of shoes out
and say
they what's that word when food when
clothes goes to Ross Dam damaged
correctly okay irregular irregular so
when the shipment of shoes would come in
she get the most expensive shoes and say
it
broke and she a pair of like when you
went to her house she had rooms filled
of $300 shoes she was that's a dream
come true she was 21 years old at the
time oh my God but everything they got
that was really worth it it was damaged
and they'd send her another box and no
don't send it back we don't care throw
it away and she would take a pair of
shoes
home she had been there since high
school like as a stock clerk and just
went to the ranks and when she got out
of high school they said listen being
the assistant manager
2 years in the chick quit to go
somewhere else she took over so beside
the bank cards we were getting we were
also getting cards of people who were
getting hit and you had to move the
cards fast so I would take them to her
to see if they were stolen before I went
out in the loose in the mall where she
worked at I would take the card to to
her first if the card was good first
thing we had to had do was buy her a
pair of
shoes we'd buy her a dress a pair of
shoes from The Joint then we walked
through the she'd walked me through the
mall she knew everybody at the mall that
was on this so they would say the same
thing bu P get what you want but on the
way I'm going to ring 50 extra and I'm
going to take 50 cash from me right so
everybody was getting paid there was
nobody getting upset when the cops come
nobody knows nothing right I I don't
remember what the guy looked like he was
[__] I don't know he
Spanish and that's it end the [__]
story you know they have to send
investigators after to you to see
uncontrolled like a they call it
something a regular business at
year prevention or something yeah
because a lot of times Vicky Pez is in
on it too Vicky Pez will say wait whoa
whoa whoa wait a so let's pretend you
come in here once a week and buy
something but I don't sell it to you you
just ring my register and you buy
whatever the [__] you want but I keep
the product right you know what I'm
saying you do that once a month after 3
months American Express going to come in
there and go there's a lot of regular
[__] activity coming out of your
goddamn
story it's so weird the [__] you learn
growing up in jerse like you wouldn't
learn this dumb this is the most stupid
information to have in your brain but
it's great to have just like just like
scams but it makes me more careful like
it makes me more careful now it makes me
more careful with my wife like I have
one credit card for a computer you want
to rob that credit card be my [__]
guest you know what I'm saying knock
yourself out it's the people who use a
lot of credit cards like I I think now
about what's going on I don't know
what's going
on but man there's a lot of [__]
kinky [__] on the
computer there's tons of kinky people
trying to get you and they'll get you
yeah they duplicate your bank info and
your bank logo and they email you and
while you're doing it you know
something's not right you're like what
the [__] what are you talking about log
on to this and you log on to that they
want everything you're like this is too
much these people are [__] scams you
know yeah those [__] Africans that
take your money that you adopted 30
million that's the oldest scam in the
book and people still buying into that
[__] like I've seen news segments and
[__] where it's like the people that got
scammed by like seen Nigerian princees
thing and it's it's it dumbfounds me
that anyone at TH this day and age what
is it this got to be like 20 years now
of the the old Nigerian SC right I get
three [__] ones a
week from just the weirdest [__] that if
you can't tell they're a scam you have
to shoot yourself
right like now you almost deserve to be
robbed right like now I know how they
even come so I just don't even open them
right like now you know what it says in
the heading how they try to trick you
but not
really it's not like they're like you
inherited a million dollars right they
don't say that no more they say
something like into the account of Mr
Diaz we have a discussion with you about
it
matter at first I was checking them cuz
I don't know what the [__] my ex-wife is
doing she put voodoo on me or she's got
tapes from me [__] Robin credit card
the [__] in San
Francisco do you ever get an email that
is allegedly from someone you know in
real life where it's like you know oh
hey you know um hey you know it it's
Joey Diaz um I'm I'm in England I lost
my passport you know it'll be like a
whole story I'm like delete
[__] but it's like you'll know the
person like really they just tweeted for
Starbucks delete if they're my friend
they call me up right right [__] you
this tail this wild tail it is I had an
email from a friend of mine that asked
me to buy
steroids and I read it that morning I'm
like what the [__] is he talking about I
had to call him up and go what the cuz
I'm sorry I got
hacked he's into steroids they went into
his account cuz they read your [__]
first to try to make it believable to
try to make it believable Jesus method
acting yeah they method they read your
[__] first then they try to make it
believable and then you fall for it
you're like what are you talking about
let me call Joey and then you're like
somebody just sent me an email saying
Joey send me $55,000 right now I'm like
[__] you I got one I was trying to find
it I can't I must have deleted it some
guy was like one of those African
Prince's one but saying I was a fan of
your podcast and I was
like I was so excited and what did he
say I that he needed money like I
haven't I
haven't I was so I was so dumbfounded I
just deleted it but I was like what is
happening they must had money that was
for you it must it was one of those two
I have to pay a small fee to get it out
and [__] listen man this is how they do
it if they send out a 100 of those
emails two people are going to go for it
what about the one I saw in 60 minutes
that one even more interesting you get a
call and it's some from the IRS saying
that you owe back taxes and if you don't
pay it within 24 hours they to come over
there and arrest you in front of your
children and [__] that happened to my
mother-in-law she got one of the calls I
I got it too I got one too right the
first year I couldn't pay my taxes in
full and I was petrified I was like H
they said Con they said contact your
attorney and I was like I don't have an
attorney and I was real nervous but then
my
mom I could just see this [__] Momo
oh my God I was petrified it was the
first time I set up a payment I was like
I set up a payment plan they can't do
this to me and then I I looked it up and
they said that like they'll never call
you they'll never do that yeah so like I
calm down but it was like a scary Happ
at this point in
life and and you hate to say this
because you don't want to be negative
towards people but at this point in life
if you fall for one of those [__]
scams you should be shot and hung you
should be ashamed of yourself any phone
scam like [__] like that you know it's
so weird that
when I first started dating my wife we
were going somewhere one day and my
wife's a really sweet girl you know
she's not Jersey tough or nothing she'll
tell me to look at that picture on the
wall or something you know and I could
goof on her but I don't that's her world
and I respect it and I love being with
her you know and uh I noticed something
about her I noticed that when homeless
people and [__] would talk to her she
would just keep walking straight and
that made me like her even more because
she's that nice that'll help you out but
she just didn't go for it she just did
not [__] go for it you know yeah and
I asked her once I go you I mean you
don't even break and she goes you know
man I don't talk to nobody on the street
I learned the lesson a long time ago if
you want to stay and it's really true
you don't need to talk to nobody nobody
like you just keep [__] walking
unless they come up to you and you see
the blood and the hole from The Gunshot
I can't help you I don't know nothing
let's walk down this alley let's do this
listen I don't know nothing yeah yeah I
don't no oblo no oblo no [__] no Alo and
you just keep [__] yelling and run
the [__] away you know you don't even
stop like there's no stopping because
they some way or another they involve
your feelings they've been doing this
all day M they do this 30 times a day
they're going to get one
person there used to be people like uh
in North Jersey like um you know the
White Castle in Newark I don't know if
you ever I don't think I ever went to
that particular one there there was a
White Castle it was just it was so close
to bille the convenience of it
outweighed the you know it's not the
best area of town um and I would be a
teenager in my in my neon like that was
my first car was like a neon like this
[__] oh it was so shitty so you would
know going to this White Castle like in
the in your car in the Drive-Thru
there's going to be a dude there's going
to be a dude who's going to linger all
day in between where you order and where
you pick up the food so even as as like
an 18-year-old girl who if my oh my God
if my parents knew like what you know
but you drive around nework like this is
this is what you do so it's like I would
have to know if I'm going to go to that
White Castle all right if the meal's
like $5 really I'll need like seven or
eight cuz I know I pretty much have to
pay off this guy to not get any [__]
while I'm getting my food that was just
a part of things sometimes how sad is
that it isn't it CRA how sad is that
sometimes I'll pull up to a 7-Eleven
I'll stay in my car and get the [__] out
of there because there's not one
homeless dude there's five of them and
you know what man they're all able I got
a heart I really get it I was that guy
[__] 15 years ago but I figured out
how to get a [__] suit and get a
briefcase and walk into buildings and
Rob Penny change or whatever the [__] it
was but the stand out there as a young
male adult and this was the story it was
like it was and it was always the same
story CU I go there all the time
thousand stories I'm with my I have my
three nephews are inside we ran out of
gas my car's here like it was the same
story every [__] time you went to
that White Castle and then like there'd
be like liquor stores where there's a
guy like a lot of the businesses like
would have the dude and it' always be
the same dude every time with the same
variation of this original tail that's
happening in that moment that they were
running that scam I'm Burbank and Lancer
I saw them running two times in two
months and it was
hilarious because she came up to me the
second time also and I wish that you
would look at me and look at my face and
go you know what that guy's heard a few
[__] stories I'm not going to go up
to him with that story I'm going to
either [__] blow him or give him a
good [__] story but she came up to me
with the kids in the truck and the
husband and then they had to fill it up
because they were trying to get out of
town
and something didn't wasn't right I you
know what I got an ATM card I just
filled up my car I can't help you and
then I went there a month later at the
same time I wasn't even going in there I
drove by but I recognized the truck and
again she was looking for money you know
have you ever seen that guy on Woodman
and right off the 101 he was in he
always wears like a full uh denim outfit
and he has a sign that he's like his
house is going to be foreclosed on he's
been there for like 3 years so what's a
nickel going to [__] do for you I
don't know you forclosure you haven't
paid your rent in 90 [__] days plus
Bank fees and [__] and you're out here
getting nickels I ain't giving you a
dick [__] you should have planned
the head you should have planned ahead
you [__] and N bro I got a lot of heart
man I donate a lot of [__] and I try to
help people out but four young dudes
might not even I'm 53 I can't pick up a
brick no more I'm talking about four
young men there that thing Larry even
went to that thing last week he worked
for one of the [__] uh committees or
some [__] but that's still that thing
where you go and your shape up and you
have to do [__] work but it's [__]
work it's better than staying in front
of the [__] 7-Eleven irritating
people then there's that lady who goes
to the 7-Eleven where where I pulled up
with the headlights and she gave me the
finger and told me to go [__] myself and
then Le TR go Lee give her a dollar she
wouldn't take it from
Lee she wouldn't take it she's in like a
wheelchair that you have to like blow
low to keep moving oh it's like it's
like the worst thing youve ever seen the
saddest [__] thing the 7-Eleven in my
area is I got to do a
documentary I got to show people the one
on [__] Magnolia into
Tunga they're going to kill somebody in
there like I you don't need to be a
fortune teller you don't need to be a
swamy just go in there 11:00 Le and
might go to all of
them the best one is the one where we go
late night and we stand outside and talk
but there's a Chinese sushi place two
doors down that stinks like [__] you
stand there and it's that old fish heads
and [__] oh god oh and the wind's
blowing off the 170 and you're trying to
eat a [__] piece of chips we usually
go get chips diet soda we talk [__] for
15 minutes but it's down the block from
the cop station so there's no action in
there there I've never gone in there
there's no disrespect at all the owners
are in in the daytime they're very nice
and whatever they're uh uh Isis but
they're nice Isis they don't bother
nobody these two guys are great the one
guy's very goodl looking NCIS yeah
they're niis Isis the one guy's very
goodlooking he has a ha do he's always
on top of it they're always on the phone
the all three of those guys that rotate
on Burbank and kofax are gentlemen then
you take that party to Lowel Canyon and
Chandler that's Isis that's C they even
killed somebody there already my God in
the daytime a homeless guy St the owner
with a bottle where there's blood
there's blood I'm telling you you go in
there at night I took Lee in there they
had the music blasting they don't make
eye contact M there's not one 7-Eleven
that you go on to that they have oh yeah
blasting blasting I think someone must
have complained cuz I've been trying to
I went in last night at like 10:30 it
wasn't on no but at night they all have
the head gear in the daytime they don't
have the head gear at night they bust
out the helmets they're ready for
[__] war in there
Jack and this one over here is getting
really [__] up the one on Magnolia and
Tunga is my favorite they used to be a
Mexican woman in the daytime Maria she
lived down the block for me I like Maria
she's got a nice kid everybody's decent
you how far did you get into her life
come on dog I don't [__] around with
people I got a personal relationship
with my 7-Eleven you understand me I'm
loyal how many times I got to tell you
that [__] whatever happened to the uh
the Indian uh bodybuilder remember him
yeah from do you remember him we had
that guy under control Vicky peza they
shipped him out when Isis came in no
that was a brand new training camp we
got
to remember you've gone in there with me
at night there's an old guy in there oh
yeah with the beard that guy is he Isis
Le he's the leader cuz I think he has
like the little he has different color
coating on his beard sometimes yep yep
yep yep does that mean something I'm not
[__] with you guys I wouldn't lie to
anybody about this [__] I've made little
observations the Indian guy that was
there before was a bodybuilder that
started doing steroids okay a little
[__] a little Isis dude but he was a
sweetheart I could go in there when
there was 30 people online with Lee and
I make eye contact with like give me a
crab and before he went to put the hot
dog on the bun he would stop and [__]
pose for me oh I had him under
control control out I had him under
control that poor little [__] dude
and one day him and his whole crew
disappeared so wait a minute what what
are you suggesting here you're
suggesting that they got big and buff
and then no there was only one guy that
got big and buff and I heard they sent
them all to Venice that whole crew got
sent to Venice and they came in with a
new crew and the crew chief leader at
Magnolia and Tung is definitely
Isis okay he's definitely Isis I don't
know about his little minions over there
they're very nice there the traffic they
get there is very bad down the block is
a
uh bus station it's a bus station and
then like and across the street there's
a park and people live in RVs and in the
middle of the night people live in the
park the cops Shake That park down every
night but you could Rambo that
[__] put a blanket over your
head and [__] with grass on it and you
get away with it they think it's like a
grass pop but they come out of that
[__] thing there's night I've been in
there and people have gone in there
[__] shoplifted and showed it to the
dudes and run out and they're like what
are we going to do we're not going to
chase this poor kid we're not going to
get nowhere we're just going to get a
line and what we going to do chase them
and get beat up by four guys and then
they'll call the cops and the cops come
and they'll check the cameras and
they'll check for them in the area but
that takes three [__] hours you know
but I've been in there with some wild I
remember that's where the hooker was the
hooker we tortured that I tortured for
like a year yeah she disappeared it's
weird it's a weird that's a weird weird
7-Eleven that's a weird 7-Eleven so the
one on Chandler they already stabbed the
owna he's dead at 11 in the [__]
morning it was closed for two weeks they
had a closed Laurel Canyon the 7-Eleven
on lurel cany and Chandler I knew two
years ago was Isis cuz I used to go in
there before I went to the store and I'm
like I've been to a lot of 7-Elevens in
my day this one's a little [__] up you
they don't treat you right they don't
make eye contact they're always on the
phone yelling
[__] and then they [__] just give
you a change they don't say thank you
they don't offer you a bag they're just
[__]
rude but I like the other one cuz we had
the one Hindu under control in there he
was bodybuilding so I chose that one but
the one by Burbank like I said it's next
to the police station but it's down the
block from that CRA Sushi I ate that
three times and I made it I never went
back there again one night in the middle
of night I had cold shakes and I woke up
like I ate that three times and didn't
get sick I ain't going back there again
it's like a three item lunch thing the
Philly roll wasn't bad but you can tell
the salmon either was a week old it was
right before they [__] go bad but it
wasn't bad the right on the C yeah the C
it's if you and they gave you a chicken
cutlet fried and something I don't know
what it was fried and I know I got a
pimple on my nose the next [__] day
in the middle of the afternoon and
[__] my 7-Eleven is so much different
than you guys in Simi Valley can I tell
you about like just my my my biggest
problem was um during the day shift and
I'm usually a nighttime person I'm
usually like midnight 2 in the morning
71v and that's always the guy in the
Bluetooth but uh during the day
sometimes there was like an an overly
friendly cashier where I was like I
don't know if I could handle all this
small talk I was just going to say Joe's
very friendly you and I are both kind of
like loners like and I knew it when you
said he's the guy with the Bluetooth
Joey knows Maria with the kid who plays
baseball right right and we're like it's
the guy in the Bluetooth I like him he
doesn't talk to me and bother me when
I'm eating my snack this is how I wanted
to go I go up to the register they I'm
going to ask for Mar Light 100's two
packs they already know it like we have
that relationship Hi how are you doing
facial recognition nice nice
relationship but there was one guy who
would take it to a level that it was
kind of weird he was kind of like young
nerdy nerdy looking white guy um white
dude yeah okay but only white dude that
worked there at all right they got to
have a [__] they got to have like a
whatever they call it yeah it's what's
that when they hire black people token
the token white oh you know when they oh
affirmative action yeah they got
7-Eleven got affirmative action we got
to hang we got to hire a white dude or a
Mexican you know they always look for a
Mexican with a be how are you today and
yeah they look for a Mexican that could
pass as an Arab oh they make him get a
beard come back when you get a beard we
like you look have you considered a
turban that was my biggest 7-Eleven
problem um this this young this young
white man is too nice I don't know if I
could keep this up how nice is Simi
Valley every time I come up and see you
I'm like I would love to live in Simi
Valley I love living in Simi Valley I
love it it's it's nothing happens
perfect I want something to happen I
drive down the 118 for 10 minutes on a
traffic freeway and boom I'm in LA and
then I'm in the mix of everybody else I
love Simi Valley is that lame no I feel
like I've lost my Edge seei Valley is
where the cops live that beat up those
black people they called it we like to
talk about that I didn't want to bring
that up they still up there well well
did you guys watch the people versus OJ
Simpson when it was on oh my God it was
like the worst PR for Simi Valley ever
they kept bringing it up the one guy in
the one scene was like I live in Simi
Valley and I love it like everyone was
glaring at him and I'm like do we live
in a racist town I didn't know my cousin
and her husband live in s Valley and
they have a very nice house he's a cop
oh a highway patrol okay and he said
that his whole block of cops like the
whole like his Captain's down the block
his Lieutenant's three blocks away you
know I never even knew about it till the
OJ thing that the SEI Valley
but I like any of those places you know
I'm always scared that if I move there
then I get a job in Hollywood and had a
drive every day that's what you're
scared of I love to live in Semi Valley
if I had to stay in Semi Valley I like I
love living in the valley if I don't
have to go over that [__] Hill for
anything once I got to go over the hill
I start getting a little ratty that
night before unless it's for something I
really want to do but if it's for
something stupid I ain't going anymore
like I am over that drive it's so I am
over that drive people do not understand
it's like when I go to Jersey I love New
Jersey I love New Jersey with all my
heart I had a lot of fun in New Jersey
and a lot of great memories like when I
moved out of here like New Jersey was
not on the map like I still remember
1997 talking to this girl that was going
to type up my resume and bio and get
everything together for me on the
computer for
$250 and what she was was a PR girl that
worked for a firm on Wilshire Boulevard
and she dated a comedian this has to be
close to 20 years ago and I'll never
forget this
we're in her house my friends there was
smoking pots she's typing like she was
great at all that stuff and I I remember
her coming over to me like I had cancer
and she goes can I talk to you about
something we shouldn't put New Jersey on
there and I go one night and she goes
New Jersey it seems so small she goes
where did you grow up I go well we came
from Cuba we lived on 205 West a she
goes leave her right there say New York
City yeah so you know me dog you're
going to put New York City on something
I take it I well at that point I'm just
trying to get work guys right so if they
wanted to be New York so be it fine but
you know what that [__] girl put on
there Hell's
Kitchen and that resume went everywhere
and one of my friends got a hold of that
resume and called me from New Jersey he
go hey man I got a problem here he goes
I saw somewhere I really till this I
still talk to him I still talk to him a
lot once a week twice a week and he said
to me hey man I saw that uh that Hell's
Kitchen what the [__] are they talking
about I remember saying that to him like
the public this publicity lady said not
to put New Jersey once The Sopranos hit
then it was all over then it was cool to
be from Jersey everybody asked you
stupid [__] creepy questions about
New Jersey and [__] if you were from
Jersey everybody assumed you were in the
mafia your uncle was in the mafia it was
so weird how one TV show Even though PE
even though
Springsteen has always publicized he's
from Jersey yeah and I thought about it
years later I'm like she cannot he's not
around no more he he tapped out so she
she was probably a bum too and I always
think about what that [__] mud is
doing like I I thought about it years
later I go wait a second Bon Joi at that
time publicized he was from Jersey
everybody knows [__] the chairman of
the [__] board is from [__]
Jersey and [__] uh
Springsteen's from Jersey okay
so what the [__] are you talking about
she's probably living in Jersey now
[__] uh who the hell knows but it's
so weird how the the the the Jersey
image has changed in 10 years like now
it's hip to be you know I heard they
built up Red Bank Red bank's really nice
I was I was just going to mention Red
Bank cuz I was there um and yeah it is
the whole all Main Street and everything
or Broad Street is that what it is they
I heard they wanted to turn it into a
place so people people didn't have to go
into the city well good luck with that
yeah no like [__] like that
entertainment I heard they were going to
build film studios out there and uh I
mean that would be just a lot every time
I go to New Jersey it changed so much
over the years and my sadness is that I
go to Jersey for three days like one of
the times I I took a train which in my
world I thought it was a blast I've
always liked that train from down the
shore to either Hoboken and then you
which and go to Grand Central or I don't
know how it really works anymore but I
would take that train all the time into
the city it went from [__] exit 17 my
buddy lived on Nolan Road I would walk
to the corner and he would drop me on
you know something you couldn't walk to
the uh tent and the [__] buses would
come all the time there in trains they
were trains every 15 minutes man and you
just got on the
train did you get the ticket and then go
on the train then the guy punched the
hole
it no no you been that's that's that
train there that they still have that in
Boston it's called The commo Rail it's
like an actual train it goes like all
all around the the state that was fun oh
it's great to me that's fun I don't
trust this train system it's not bad I
don't know why the red it isn't [__]
bad what the one here the the Metro yeah
I don't trust the [__] earthquake
value and I don't trust the train New
York anymore a bomb under there you're
[__] done Jack if you're on 49 if
you're on 72nd Street waiting for the
train and that bomb goes off on 86
you're getting done this train I I never
trust I never
feel hunky dory you know I grew up in
the old trains with graffiti and people
getting stabbed on the train I the best
was every train you get on in those days
in the
80s the train would open people would
empty Lee listen to me you're going to
love this Lee on demand this was on
demand every time you took the train you
saw this guy twice a day the train would
open empty would train out the nuk
people get back on the train the door's
closed the guys the guy goes keep your
hands away from the door because they're
about to close right after that word
you'd hear the front door open like that
door in the front that somebody comes
walking and some guy would come walking
in and he go excuse me excuse me and
need your attention ladies and gentlemen
I'm put a hat on the floor but let me
tell you what's going on in my life
right now he would [__] go into this
speech about he had cancer he had HIV I
got a tumor I got a fungi toe I got
liver disease all of it all of this [__]
oh no and he would sit there with a hat
and nobody would give him a [__]
nothing and then he would go to the next
train and the door wouldn't close and
you'd hear him doing the same [__]
speech in there and and much like the
forcl closure that you mentioned earlier
this is another what's a nickel going to
do situation for sure I don't know
anymore like I said I'm very generous I
know who's bullshitting me you know
who's bullshitting you in life sometimes
you don't even give a [__] you just go
you know what give this guy a doll he's
out here by himself it's cold whatever
the [__] like the ones I saw today I
went to 7-Eleven today there was a dude
with a Dodger hat standing there asking
for donations then there was three of
them by the [__] tank by the gas tank
and they yell over at you hey give me a
[__] D like hey you got a quarter the
spare I got a whole [__] cup of
change in the middle of my glove
compartment there that little thing that
I will give you if you ask me the right
way if you walk up to me like a man and
go is and I haven't eaten in [__] 3
days look at me can you help me out I'm
trying to get a job I don't have a job
I'll help you out man it's those guys
that are just waiting there and they get
10 nickels and they figure out how to
smoke crack and they go into a hole and
it's on me like I'm supposed to [__]
feel bad because I don't give them a
dollar [__]
them [__] them [__] I learned
when I lived in Boston that you can't
you have to like kind of scout the area
out and you can't do it if like you're
going to see them every day cuz I made
that mistake once like I got off at the
same train stop every day for 3 years
and you give it and you gave I gave it
to one guy that was it for like a few
weeks and I was like God I had I got off
at a different stop for a couple days
just to like to lose them lose them oh
yeah they're great in Boston there's one
guy who yells all day and like he yells
with a horse voice anybody got any spare
change he just walks up and down [__]
you there there's a woman in Cambridge
who like the IRS is going after cuz she
made over 100 Grand
panhandling what that's more money than
I made listen man if you slick it
up you can make a lot of money
if you slick it up and attack Prime Time
on the train or a bus in the
morning you can make a lot of money
there was a guy 30 years ago that would
dress up in a suit and walk up and down
Time Square and say Excuse me sir I just
got mugged can I get $10 to get home and
everybody would give him 10 20 $30 cuz
he had a suit on different game clean
shaving nice hair
manicured I just been robbed I don't
know what to do the cops can't help me I
have no money to get home I live in Long
Island all I need to do is get $10 from
you he would start at 8:00 in the
[__] morning 7:30 that's a good one
that's a good one by lunchtime 3 four
[__] hundred 6 days a week that's
2400 that's close to 10 G's a [__]
month Jesus and he would switch it up
from Grand
Central to Time Square to to to other
parts yeah you can't you can't have the
same 70s I remember 2020 hadam on and he
would wear nice suits and nice hair and
just just Hey listen man like I said
I'll help anybody I had that guy close
to my house the black dude that was a
genius wouldn't take my money wouldn't
take my money I asked him 10 times
please take this 20 get something to
drink it's 90° no brother I'm fine he
would go over the you ever drive on
Chandler now and there's a bridge you
ever see that bridge Le we see it all
the time and there's graffiti and
there's always somebody know they
jerking off they got like a 13-year-old
in the back moaning and they're jerking
off in the front seat there but nobody
ever stop up
there by that wall there there's a fence
and he lives down there he goes behind
that fence and he he set up like a
compartment cops don't bother him
nothing and he gets exercise there it's
amazing and it's his and nobody [__]
with this black dude and he made it so
he could push his shopping cart back
there and he's got like hubcaps and
books in there magazines and somebody
gave him like a thing to watch movies
on it's pretty brilliant I respect those
guys yeah and I offered him money a
couple times I would take the baby on a
stroll and I'd see him and talk to him
and he told me what he used to do he had
a family and [__] he wasn't drunk he was
coherent wow I dropped off clothes one
time I went there 2 days later it was
gone you know so he took the clothes and
stuff I've always wanted to talk to some
of those people who live in the RVs cuz
I've never seen that before I've seen
homeless people and it's terrible and I
but that I feel like that's a different
there's a difference yeah but those RV
people are not homeless by choice I
guarantee they're having a great time
yeah I had a girlfriend who had an RV
dog one day this [__] told me I'm I'm
getting an RV there's an RV camp in uh
where where uh Henry Hill used to live
in Seattle R Renton Renton Washington
this place was tremendous guys it was
like a 100 a
week to park the
RV wow you took showers was inside there
was a pool there was a weightlifting
thing there was a dry cleaner there was
a restaurant there was a movie
theater are you [__] crazy there was
a post office there was a bank there was
a whole world in there a whole little
Community whole little community and you
backed in your RV they had different
spots if you want to be close to the
[__] all the mall or if you want to
be 50 yards away or 100 yards away I was
a
comic you know I didn't have any money I
had a car but all I did was do comedy
then and I and she asked me she goes if
you could behave yourself you can live
here that's not Coke and [__] so I said
ah let's give it a try it was a great
two or three months we had up there it
was great I'd wake up in the morning
jump in the pool yeah we get out there
were steam bats they had a sauna I you
had like the [__] shampoo in there
you could shave and then you [__]
went to the restaurant you had breakfast
they had two eggs bacon nice I me Lee
[__] nice I'm telling you that sounds
like fun but these people are like
living right they well listen that's a
party over there Lee think so that's a
party over there because okay
so I don't know if they're homeless
necessarily because remember I used to
do kettle bells over there right yeah
and I would drive by there and it's the
same people every day that just move it
there and some people are out some
people park it there and go to a job I
think yeah I think some people just live
there but like and it gets even CRA and
then they get back there remember they
could leave it there till 10: at night
then they have to move it somewhere if
you go there right now there's no
there's nothing there really you have to
by law go there right now on the way
home go that
way you can't park up by the park no
more at night only by the residential
area you can park but no those trailers
got to move at night Jimmy boy you can
uh Park in Walmart right isn't that LE
isn't that like a thing Walmart let you
park RVs or anything I think people talk
about it when you're like driving cross
country to park in Walmart parking lots
but right now
you're you get
divorced you lose your
house you
know you don't really know what you want
to do you look at the paper there's an
RV for sale for [__] 10 grand that
you could that's ready to go the
engine's [__] strong it's got air
conditioning it's got Direct TV oh I'm
already sold listen yeah you know and
you go you know what let me give this a
shot and you know what Lee I got to tell
you something you can put a lot of money
away if you could do it for three years
and figure out the ins and out how to
cook have a friend that cooks you can
sleep there two nights a week you sleep
in your RV you got TV but it's have to
have air condition like Kate when Kate
qu quigly came on she had an idea she
goes I want to move to the beach by
myself you're going to get stabbed and
[__] raped don't take a [__]
genius to tell you that but you know if
you guys whatever you didn't want to
work and you wanted to try something
it's not a bad [__] life for 6 months
man I think I could do it for a short
amount of time they have
kitchens listen you're not going to cook
manot and [__] steak Pizza all and
[__] the meal of the seven dishes
Christmas eat some chicken though you
can make soup you can bring Coke Cuts
you can make ziti you can make salads
you can make protein shakes you have to
get a generator you
know it's not a bad life for like I said
I did it and I'm a [__] picky [__] it
wasn't bad because of the situation we
had the one where you could take showers
in there I mean yeah you have 8 minutes
to take a [__]
shower but that that where you were
parking it seems amazing so [__] those
showers no I know we didn't use those
showers but listen man God you know a
couple years ago people lost their homes
for closure with all that [__] that went
down with mortgages yeah that was the
easiest way out to get an
RV you know they you know you know
Felicia lives down there right yeah if
you keep going down and you make a right
you'll see five or six of them over
there at night there's spots all around
here that you pull up with your RV you
keep your mouth shut you bring a
sandwich in you watch your TV you go to
bed nobody says nothing to you but you
can't be at that Park did you see that
on the East Coast I
didn't I don't I don't remember it I was
too young and I didn't look for it and I
didn't really that's also that also
could be true that I didn't notice it
yeah no I didn't really know I mean
there were I I remember there being mo
mobile homes trailer parks things like
that but no I don't
remember tons I know the my brother
lives in an RV that they just made into
a home you you know those things yes
lives in Delaware where they they get an
RV they put two of them together they
weld them yes they get a good toilet
system like it's a good toilet system
they give you a backyard they give you a
[__] front steps they give you a I
don't know if they give you a
garage and it's an RV that's designed to
be a home and that wasn't bad I went to
visit my brother that wasn't bad they
had a pool in the back couldn't be that
[__] bad you know yeah
I want a pool so [__] bad like to me
to have a pool in my yard like an in
ground pool that would be the ultimate
the ultimate thing I want ground pool
really yeah yeah just a dig ground pool
I mean like we have we rent a house I
don't own the house but it's a nice
house and I've been there a lot of years
um I always say like I never ever want
to leave this house but the truth is if
another house came along that had an
inground pool in the backyard to me it's
like oh that's it would you swim every
day in in my head I think I'd swim every
day whether whether I would actually go
through with that I don't know but I
would love to yeah in yeah in my head I
go out in the morning smoke a cigarette
go in the pool maybe just hang by the
pool maybe type by the pool do my work
by the pool I'm nice would it be to get
up drink a cup of
coffee go on social media do all your
work on social media go outside smoke a
joint finish a cup of coffee jump in the
[__] pool once you got some
momentum before breakfast
do 10 laps heated or not huh is it a
heated yes in this fantasy it's Absol
when you wake up you you press the
button and you give it 45 minutes you
jump in that [__] you do 10 20
laps brother you get out you run right
into the shower you wash your monkey you
put your clothes on you eat breakfast
and you [__] go out in the world like
a Savage you just did 20 [__] laps in
the pool you know you started your
morning with an hour in the pool you
know you're bodies on
fire how great would it be yeah I like
pools too I we have a pool but they shut
it down we still got a yard but the pool
is is done you know I mean it would have
been a lot more [__] dough if I got a
pool I don't need no [__] pool right
right if I ever get enough money to buy
a house I love a pool a nice lap pool
with you know Felicia Michaels has a
tremendous pool oh really and they've
gotten it it maybe five times no no he
did long faps a Jacuzzi the back oh my
god when you when it's in front of you
it's amazing how okay you could buy
swings for your child right and they
have a horse in the back and a [__]
Treehouse they'll do it three or four
times then they'll neglect it they go to
some other kid's house you can't get
them out of the [__] Treehouse you
know you can't get them off the [__]
swings you got to swing in your backyard
that's the problem with that stuff that
once you have it you just go ah okay I
have a pool been there done that well
even when you're like would you swim
every day and it's like well I imagine I
Would S every day um I mean no not
especially I just I love to swim I like
going in the ocean oh yeah yeah I know
how to swim let me tell you something
you jump in the pool in the morning
before I got locked up a buddy of mine
that worked at UPS was like yeah I go
how do you stay so [__] yolked and he
goes I got three kids I can't I I I got
time to lift twice a week for 30 minutes
I got to do it my kids are in the shower
or something he said and he goes but the
rest of the time I
swim and he talked me into going to
master swimming program and I'll tell
you jumping in the pool first thing in
the morning there's a thousand things
you could do first thing in the morning
I mean getting up getting a protein
shake smoking a little toots I would
ride my bike there because it was four
blocks away and I I knew how to get
there without even messing with cars you
know so I'd get my blood going a little
bit that way I get in take my shorts off
I'd have a a [__] bikini on already
and you jump in and she'd blow a whistle
and make you do laps or pulls or just
kicks and when you got out of that pool
your body feels completely [__]
different I would love to have a heated
pool now where I could go in there at 7
to 7:45 to show cuz I was doing it the
YMCA in Welling in Hollywood they got
the big pool which is cold but they got
the heated pool in the back that's 90°
and it's empty at 6 so I would go steam
sauna and then jump in that [__]
and do 30 minutes and then go back steam
sauna throw some
eal
Ealy Epal litical no
eucalypticola
and put it on the pipes and just sit
there and breathe and [__] it was
tremendous I love all that [__] I if
anything I wish I had
now I wish I had a a steam wow like a
fits like that I could go in there and
put hot water and get the top layer of
[__] [__] out of your skin every
morning I wish I had one of those that I
like those fcking awesome and if it's
yours you can go in there balls ass with
ass sweat and burn the hemorrhoids off
your muffler just sit on the [__]
ball I grill it like I grilled my
hemorrhoid and [__]
you me that the hot bar that you're
supposed to get the steam from you're
going to sit on your it's a finger
speed the finger [__] speed
s the other thing I always wanted and I
finally got was a pool table um we
finally like have a pool table in our
house where like you Le you've been to
my house you know the D the dining room
or what should be a dining room is now
the pool table room yeah that's [__]
it's like oh but we won't have a dining
room [__] it who cares everything's gone
pool table now takes up everything I
just took out my dining room table my
mom thought I was crazy I was like I've
sat on it like twice never used it like
why am I going to have a table I'm just
going to sit we're going to watch TV
anyways and by dining room table by
dining room table I mean a like 6ot
folding table from Home Depot with like
a tablecloth over it by dining room
table on mean a $70 table from Ikea that
wasn't unfinished wood right in in an
apartment Flor
L yeah no we guys I got to make a
confession to you guys okay when me and
Terry got together we had the
one-bedroom apartment there was really
no kitchen so we ate in the living room
like
Savages and we always kept saying when
we move into the next place we got to
have a living and then we moved into the
valley and again we had the kitchen and
there was a living room but there was
really no space like to break it up into
a a mock dining room one of the best
things about this place that we moved
into is we have a Mark dining room and
I'm about to tell you guys something we
moved in there September 1st and since
September 1st I make it a point that we
sit at the table Mercy says
prayers and we eat whether it's
breakfast lunch or dinner tonight we had
two s bread hot dogs that's it two sa
bread hot dogs we we went who had the
baby we went to the Disney Store and we
[__] around and then we came home and
my wife goes I feel bad I don't have
dinner I I'll make a she goes I got a
Sab bread hot dog for you they got them
now so she made me two Sab bread she cut
up some onions with some [__] mustard
oh and even that I we sat down and mercy
said prayers and then we ate cuz she
goes to the Catholic School not a
Catholic school but a Christian School
they don't say our father who are now
what's the Catholic one bless us our
Lord where we about to eat from your B
tea from Christ Our Lord amen we don't
say that when we say something else they
don't do the sign of the cross but I do
I always dread you know that's the way I
was raised for years my mother was a
[__] nutcase and she drank and stuff
but there was one thing for sure at my
home that kept the house together was
except for her she could do whatever the
[__] she wanted she'd talk she'd eat
standing up but I was raised to sit down
and eat and and it was just me and my
mom and my stepdad so it got kind of
[__] boring after a while and then
things happen and you evolve but even
the homes I lived in after that I saw
that people weren't respecting that
anymore you know people think I'm a
[__] dick because I don't work on
Sundays and way before the baby came way
before the baby came I hated Sundays I
always I liked working comedy Sundays
but it got to a point when when I met my
wife that you left on Tuesday and you
didn't come back till till Monday
morning and I didn't mind being away I'm
trying to make a living and I'm trying
to become a better comic but Sunday you
sit there all day watch football at this
time I could be sitting with my
girlfriend we could be going to the
farmers market or just that that's her
time you know so at that point in my
life like 2003 I decided that I wasn't
going to work Sundays no more no matter
what was going on and number two that we
were going to try to have a dinner and
sit on Sundays because that's the whole
thing that I think we're missing right
now yeah you know even my [__] up
upbringing on Sundays we'd watch like
Animal Kingdom and and the wide world of
Disney or or and you watch that [__]
dude that used to do this [__] on
channel ABC on Sunday nights you know it
was just white people on the show going
like this with that music and they would
sing quartets and [__] but that's what
it meant to be an American to me when I
came from Cuba at the time was to watch
those shows that's how I became an
American you know all Mutual Omaha was a
show about animals on NBC that went on
at 600 and at 7 it was [__] wide
world of Disney so you on Sunday nights
you always sat with your family and
watch Disney well Disney don't give a
[__] they replaced it with football so
the gambling [__] addicts could get
their [__] fix on Sundays you know
but that's one thing I've done since I
moved into this home that we sit now we
sit we like every night I go I hear
Daddy time for dinner if I don't get up
immediately immediately she runs in
there daddy time for dinner Danny hurry
up we're going to eat Danny I just I
already know when they're doing it cuz I
don't want to hear her we sit down we
look at each other every once in a while
she sticks her finger in the ketchup and
licks and like oh whoa whoaa you got to
say [__] prayers all right she says
her prayers and we attack and E if I say
attack she gets pissed like if she says
a prayers and I go attack Daddy don't
say that no yelling in the house so we
yell it inside voice Daddy yeah oh
[__] hysterical it's important my mom
my you met my mom last week the the
amount of dinners I ate in the living
room or the amount of dinners I ate
watching TV as a kid zero we ate every
meal at a table always ate at the table
every meal my dad worked night sometimes
so he wasn't there all the time but he
uh we never we we didn't have a TV on
that
floor my mom hates TV we did have a TV
in our kitchen though a little black and
white one though like that wasn't a
thing at the time like late
we can't watch the TV when we're eating
but I'm going to turn it off from now
and out of respect as long as we put it
back on for 6:30 I got to watch my
[__] day you watch it after on
[__] ABC World News Tonight I want to
hear that I want to hear what that kamie
[__] got the tell me you know what I'm
saying let me give some shout outs real
quick here where my [__] glasses God
damn it how you feeling dog I'm pretty
[__] high right now I like it I like
it I don't want to give you a [__] I
don't want to give you a fayi product I
want to thank my
man Stephen utzman from Texas listen to
this boob Lingus this [__] sent
me a signed Hollywood Henderson poster
are you [__] kidding me or what the
poster is so [__] bad Bobby Lingus I
got to get the [__] framed so I
thank you Lingus for dropping two books
on me about Hollywood Henderson and want
to thank my man Steph utman from [__]
the the beautiful state of [__] Texas
God Bless Texas [__] I will be
there Friday night Houston at the come
and take it Festival go to come and take
it I don't know.com I don't know [__]
Google it do what you need to do Friday
night 10:00 you can get home from work
wash your monkey shave it go to [__]
kabas get a nice Italian dinner and
still catch Joey at [__] 10:00 how's
that for you come and take it comedy.com
come and take it comedy.com $35 for
Friday night past you got Todd Barry at8
and you got Uncle Joey at 10 who the
[__] that's 1750 a piece what are you
crazy or what I'm giving you a nickel
right off the C get those tickets right
now Friday at 10 but he's from the great
state how about Jr Gomez my man John
Cutler and his beautiful wife Amy lady J
ukie spooky my man Bonito Reverend
Raymond shet ngog and inward journey I
love you [__] stay black and
thank you for supporting the show and
whatnot how you feeling Le right I'm
feeling pretty pretty good it wasn't
matter Le I made you all nervous when I
was you I was doing the finger a d you
know what I'm saying you know how to
torture people what am I ain't torturing
you you're F do you know how to make my
heartbeat when I'm
high I can make your heartbeat when I'm
not [__] high that's that's that's
the secret then what else is going on
Micky PE tell me something I haven't
heard tell me some gossip who got hit by
a car what happen oh oh I remember
something I wanted to talk to you guys
about cuz the last time or one of the
one of the times I was on we we talked
about weddings like in depth and how
[__] insane and and out of control
weddings are list listen to me before
you even start the [__] weddings out
day I'm just so you know uh if you see
my face getting red just down 911 I'll
explain you
want right now I'm in The Verge I got a
backache in September my brother Lenny I
got a back ache I never got a I got the
back of a Mexican you understand me you
never seen a Mexican with a back brace
or complain about back paint they just
God gave them a good [__] back they
got to jump off fence they got to got a
if you got to jump off fence you got to
have a good back okay so I hurt my back
and I swear to God I think it was
thinking about the special sitting down
that long long trying to write out the
jokes I've never really sat that long to
write that long but the third thing I
was getting aggravated about is I love
her she's my
sister but she's making all these plans
for a wedding for me to fly back there
and go to a rehearsal dinner with my
family my daughter my wife and then sad
I got to walk it down the aisle and all
this comes out of Papa's pocket like the
three plane tickets the [__] hotel
the rental car and you're sitting there
adding this up this is New York City you
go to New York City you gotta have deep
[__] pockets for three days even
though my family enjoys it and she'll
enjoy it my wife doesn't really want to
do it yeah my wife feels it's too much
of a commitment with people we don't we
know her right and we know her mother we
don't know anybody else at this wedding
we'll just be sitting there like [__]
targets you know and then we have the
baby who gets car sick they're doing the
wedding in Garfield have you been to
Garfield where the [__] is it um it's
nice right yeah it's pretty nice it's
not it's it's a little bit down the
parkway she's
45 you think she's 21 okay so I've
always said and I have nothing against
women there's a there's two things when
women are
completely you know either you give them
a Cosby pill that's one way to get them
under the [__]
ether or when they're getting married or
they're having a baby and I I don't mean
to disrespect women by no means I have
every right to say it I have a beautiful
wife and I saw the changes in her
personality and then I started noticing
other women's changes when a woman's
about to get married or have a child
they get [__] delusional okay they
get delusional in their own sense with
weddings they get really delusional I
mean she was telling me and my wife to
our faces last year now I wouldn't mind
if she was 21 and she was my niece right
right right right she's 46 she got glass
is this her first marriage yeah okay she
got registered at the cisal place come
on
you're not getting a spsky crystal for I
had my wife get us something
bro I had my wife get something get
something but you could already see
where this is number two I don't have
the time to just take three nights off
if I'm going to get on a plane for 6
hours I want something out of it to me
I'm so used to getting on a plane for 6
hours but I get to perform yeah I can't
just commit to you Thursday's the church
rehearsal Friday is the rehearsal dinner
at some [__] restaurant in Middle New
Jersey and then Saturday's the the
wedding I got to go to the wedding and
the church are you [__] crazy are you
[__] crazy I would never do Coke but
if I got to sit through that for 3 Days
by Saturday I'm on something I'm on
Xanaxes I'm on [__]
something so what happened with your
wedding I just came I came back from New
Jersey because I was the maid of honor
at my sister's wedding okay and my
sister um they're young she was like 26
27 I think the I get that I get it right
they had just bought a they bought a
house they already own a house together
in January so it's like they've been
engaged a few years but uh yeah they're
they're young um and this could have
been cuz this uh you know my
brother-in-law now like his his family
like they've done big weddings for the
daughters like this could have really
been all out they wanted to keep it kind
of small but still small it's like a
hundred people you you know what I mean
it's still a huge deal so yeah there was
a lot of like events like what you're
talking about and one of them one of
them was like the night of the day of
the rehearsal dinner um we we went axe
throwing they had a bunch of people go
Hatchet throwing it was Hatchet throwing
at this place then you go do the
rehearsal dinner it was like such a huge
to do but I had to throw the
bachelorette party and that's the story
I wanted to tell on here I had to throw
the bachelorette party in August so I
had to go home twice cuz I also had to
do the bridal shower cuz I'm the maid of
honor my mother really planned most of
it but you know so I it was me and two
other girls in the bridal party and the
girls are my brother-in-law's sisters so
my sister wants to go to Atlantic City
she wanted to stay at Bergata I I came
home I go to make a reservation at
Bergata it's booked so now I'm panicking
cuz I'm not thinking it's August in New
in New Jersey in Atlantic City on a
Saturday night so I [__] panic and I
think well I I got to book the strip
club now because I'm too [__] scared
if Borat is booked what else is going to
be booked so I booked this place called
hunko Mania that's a mail review and I
and because I don't know who's going yet
I book it for a VIP booth for
12 for 12 girls but I don't know I don't
know how many are going to deliver for
me but I I'm over booking everything cuz
that one booking was [__] we got a a
room at Resorts that I'm basically like
I hope we can all shove into one after I
book all this
[__] out of the two bridesmaids
basically they flat out both tell me
that they're not going to go and that
they're
against male reviews and strippers as if
I like they made it seem girls yes Tom's
River yeah they got to get it together
Tom's River they've been buying it
they've been watching the Kardashians
too long I mean and I'm like and to me
it's inconceivable because it's like
well what do you mean you what do you
mean you don't want it like this is one
of one of them said it it's not my thing
it's not your thing it's it's not your
[__] thing it's my thing it's my
that's Lee that's my thing hun Mania I
love going to I love watching Magic Mike
it's a [__] bachelorette party what
else am I supposed to do so only only
two of them ended up coming to Atlantic
City the two other bridesmaid so I'm
paying for [__] 12 I'm going to be
paying for this forever it was so much I
charged it it was so much one of the
girls find finally caved and came with
us the other one stayed in the hotel
room didn't leave the hotel room all
night and when we came back from the
2hour show she was like in bed in her
pajamas then the other one got in bed
old they ordered room service they're
both younger than me um maybe uh 30 28
mared they're both married they both
have kids young kids and they both my
sister for when they were getting
married did all their [__] and now it's
like her turn and and I got the vibe
that it was like because they have kids
they feel like they can't do like to me
this is so [__] it's it's corny like
I'm sure you guys have never been to one
of these but no I've never been to it's
like the movie Magic mic nothing happens
there's not like dicks out they're not
slapping you with dicks it's it's
nothing crazy it's like a a Broadway
play but you know there's Speedos on and
they rub their [__] so [__]
corny especially like um doing things
like with the naughty show and like
going to going to the avns for for years
for me this is Fu like I just want to
say do you understand I judge like a
porn star [__] competition and you
don't want to go see a guy dance in a
[__] bikini like how and and one of
them the girl when we left she goes she
goes that was the most intense
experience of my life and I thought holy
[__] [__] that's so sad that's
imagine it's crazy I've never I've never
been part of any of those things okay I
left North Bergen before any of those
things happened in my life I could tell
you guys sincerely I don't you remember
going to a [__] bachelor party I've
been married twice at my bachelor party
the first time was me my friend George
and my brother-in-law doing an eightball
watching some [__] video cuz I had
like four days I knew I didn't have to
piss in a bottle for the halfway house
and I knew I could let myself go that
was my best part I didn't think of women
as strippers and and I'm a filthy
[__] animal you know what I'm saying
but I get the uh the bond you have
especially coming from New Jersey
there's six of us we all help out on our
weddings and you got married you did
this and everybody went now it's a
different game so you want to take you
ball and go home right even me who I'm a
[__] like when it comes to that if
Lee came to me and one of his friends or
his brother called me and so listen Lee
wants to go to a strip club the one in
Van eyes you know want from 8 to n it
wouldn't kill me Lee wants to see me for
10 minutes and talk to his high school
friends right I could go in there get a
lab dance buy him a lab dance and leave
you
know I could do that and I could even
handle that I could even handle that one
right there especially if all I got to
do is down to block in Atlantic City if
you make me go to kovver City by the
airport I ain't showing right you know
what I'm saying if it's one of those
strip clubs I ain't showing this is like
we got we got the room at resorts on the
boardwalk beautiful ocean view room
expensive [__] room and you're going
down [__] an elevator and walking
like a block to this like theater in
Atlantic City where these guys do this
[__] I did I I thought I was doing a
corny wholesome like you know what I
mean five girls going out let's have
some drinks right ex they toasted [__]
you know what I'm saying we're guys
exactly we get the champagne oh my God
we're going to who brought singles like
I think I'm playing the role I think I'm
doing what I'm supposed to be doing
that's not me that's not who I am I
think I'm I think this is what everybody
wants and it's like as soon as I book
that [__] the whole thing turned on me
and and all of a sudden then it was like
I was some sex crazed Heathen trying to
drag you know their their uh
Brothers the next day they looked at you
were all weird and nobody was really
hung on and then what am I supposed to
do too cuz the idea too that anyone like
I I had to like sneak away and this is
in New Jersey now I had to sneak away at
one point and like smoke pot on the
street by myself cuz I can't even
[__] smoke pot in the room cuz I can
already if you're not walking in the
mail review I'm not lighting up this
[__] joint in this hotel room the way
going to you smoke in a hotel room
that's the way it's going to be first
off they charge you 250 and that's if
somebody doesn't complain that's if the
maid smells it and if they don't
complain if they somebody complains then
they have to knock on your door I'm
worried about the act the the people I'm
with complaining like it's so far in to
anything that I'm used to being
around nuts nuts a conversation how my
mom died the anniversary was last week
30 something years it that you know but
Le and I and his mom went on it was
really interesting to do it you know you
really don't know what you have till you
lose it I Live Now in wherever the [__]
I live Valley
Village least 28 years old I haven't
doing this I torment him two days a week
plus three days a week on the phone then
I go on the road I I don't want to take
Lee
anywhere you know I love Lee to death
Lee go Lee knows we go to dinners we
have nice times but for me to call Lee
at 11 and go like I know Lee will go
with me to New York minute to [__]
the burger place and I know Lee will do
a thousand things with me but Lee Rogan
uh Ari guys like that they I love them
dearly but they don't feel the void
by the style of people I grew up with in
Jersey and I was really feeling it the
last couple years that every time I go
to Jersey it's basically a work
situation yeah like when I fly in
Wednesday night Thursday morning I do op
and Anthony Thursday night I do the
stand Friday I do Gotham Saturday I do
Gotham and I'm on the first flight at
6:00 a.m. and either I got to see him at
the shows which is a 3-minute
conversation because I got 270 people
standing there waiting to take a picture
yeah and waiting to tell me their story
about life and stuff and it started
bothering me and then uh a guy from our
neighborhood Carmine Bano the cop who
shot the guy in the back seven times in
self-defense he died and I and at the
Wake they took they went to my teacher's
bar and they took pictures and these
were kids that I know since the sixth
grade and I and I contacted each of on
Facebook and I said listen man I'm going
to fly in but this time on Thursday I'm
not going to the stand yeah I'm going to
go to Baron's bar our seventh grade
teacher's bar meet me there and two
girls in the sixth grade three girls
four girls in the sixth grade
came uh a kid from the eighth grade came
another friend of mine from the seventh
grade came and Mr Bron the teacher wow
and we just sat there for 3 hours nobody
got
hammered nobody they didn't you know
they don't even know about the reaper I
smoke like I would even bring it up I
went in there half lit you know but I
got to tell you as simple as that was it
made my year like and I was home by
10:30 quarter to 11:00 I remember the
girls were like at 9:30 like boy we're
getting tired but I know these girls
since the sixth [__] grade then I
ended up doing seventh grade I got left
back and they got to the eighth grade
but I still remain friends with them so
it's like now I want to get more
involved in those type of things with my
friends like I have a friend who has a
band The Past
Masters they they're a [__] cover
band he's a great kid I mean I've been
hanging out with him since we were 12 he
had a shed behind this house and he had
drums back there and a guitar no heat
though so in the de of February you were
back there with gloves on and a [__]
snorkel and he has he has a band called
The Past Masters and I'm thinking of
looking at his schedule and maybe flying
in and just surprised him cuz he he went
to my mom's [__] funeral he went to
my mom's [__] wake you know like
that's how long I know him you know and
it's five guys who have day jobs he's an
engineer uh he works at sax Coleman or
something like he's one of a financial
investor or something like that and
there like five guys like that that are
well off they have great jobs and they
have a band and they play All Around
Jersey and they do Springsteen and they
do you know some Bon Joi and you know
whatever The Who and whatever and they
do but every time they have a show close
to my hometown a bunch of people whether
it's Maywood or [__] like that people
show up you know so it'd be great to see
those guys again so that's why I would
get pissed at your two friends like I
would go upstairs and straight them out
like listen ladies let me talk to you
sit down for a
second you girls got lady you guys got
husbands you got kids I get it you want
to be respectful you got to go down
there for 15 minutes you got to put a
[__] dress on I got some weed when
was the last time you and they'll look
at you go marijuana oh my God how
juvenile I don't give a [__] that's what
you guys need you need two hits of this
weed or a black dick up your ass to
loosen you up a little bit you're
married and with a kid we don't want you
to go out and get raped and meet a guy
that's not what we're saying but have a
good time for 10 [__] minutes 10
minutes go in there giggle see how
cheesy it is look at that guy he thinks
and I'm older I'm older than both of
them I've been married long than both of
them um and one of them is married twice
already on their second marriage so it's
kind of like and younger than me so it's
kind of like hey I know you're no Angels
so let's cut the [__] this is all about
this isn't about what me what I want or
what you want this is about my sister my
nice sister who's been so nice to
everyone my sister's [__] an angel
you have to understand and so is the kid
she's marrying they're so nice and
innocent that's what made it so funny to
see her get picked up on the stage by
the black guy in the bathing suit okay
cuz she's this dainty little girl and he
was winging her around and we're
throwing money it's just fun it's just
fun it's just fun it's not dirty and
it's that's it's a reason to scream and
get drunk if you're a girl godamn it and
we everyone should have been on board I
I hadn't been in the strip club since
like 1999 in Canada before 9911 when I
go to Toronto I would go to BL Street
best strip clubs in the world beside the
one I grew up in New Jersey with the
frozen bananas and [__] this one didn't
have frozen bananas but the women were
more risque that put that bush in your
face oh manad you know I don't know it
just wasn't for me yeah no strip clubes
W for me and it started bothering me
like at The Comedy Store the body shops
down the corner you don't know how many
times those guys have gone to the body
shop and I'm like no and they're like
why what is the problem I even dated the
strip for 4 years is when I moved to LA
I moved here with a stripper oh wow and
then she danced on lasa and then she
just went crazy and started dancing
[__] in the valley or whatever but I
wasn't dating her anymore and she still
dances once a week and she's a
psychiatrist she has a fulltime job as a
psychiatrist in some [__] place and
then 3 hours from her house like on
every other Sunday she goes she has a
bunch of regulars she gives hand jobs oh
wow she'll [__] you for 200
so she's really in It For the Love of
the Game like she's she was you know she
grew up in a cult she had to [__] the
Lita she had to cut his toenails and
[__] what do you think what do you think
happens to you that [__] sticks at you
like herpes for the rest of your
life but uh so last year I finally broke
down last holiday I went to The Comedy
Store on a Sunday night I had a great
set I was driving back and I missed my
exit I kept going on the 170 when I made
the right boom there was the strip club
and I made a u-turn I went in I got a
lap dance I didn't get a drink it was
empty the girl was great her boyfriend
listened to the podcast you know who I
was oh my God we talked I tried to ask
can I lick your monkey she said not at
all you know what I'm saying cuz you
there's a lot of [__] you won't do when
you go to the strip club until it's
right in front of you when they dance
new in front of you and it's right here
it takes about 3 seconds that you want
to bite that [__] [__] all a sudden
you're feeling like Trump and you're
like I can't do this [__] I can't
[__] CP I've never been to one I I
you have never been to a strip never
even walked into one even I've been to a
a female one I wouldn't know what to do
with you this I wouldn't know I want to
take you to one where you can get your
pipe sucked really I don't think do they
exist anymore [__] yeah d by the airport
did they exist anymore yeah where Eddie
Bravo used to work you take those girls
upstairs they suck your pipe for [__]
the deuce the small nickel well I I knew
like the massage parlers existed but I
figured these places might be a little
bit more like uh regulated now no
there's no regulation it's just you it's
the oldest profession yeah they start
dancing it persever it finds way a
little they get a little freakier you
throw 20 at them or 50 another yard
stick what how much am I spending for
this blow jum who gives a [__] make them
lick your nuts make them pay for it make
them drink the juice of debt you know
what I'm
saying see now now now I think she has
herpes because she's going to suck my
dick for $170 well who gives a [__] if
she got herpes so you never had heres
before no biggie you take a couple pills
you drink some orange juice that's a
biggy I you're back within a week who
you kidding they got new medicine now
you get the her just tell Paula she got
to move out for a month ain't no dick
sucking a [__] this month Paula why
not cuz I'm on new medication I have no
erection oh my God meanwhile you're
leaking you need a diaper for your
little helmet and [__] I don't think
heres just goes away like that well what
it's got to do something it's got to go
somewhere you got to stays there for
whatever it goes dormant for a little
while that's what those commercials are
about sudden you just give Paul the herb
that's
it it won't matter she'll never know
then just will glue a wart to your hand
and tell her you got it from a water or
something throw a toad in the bed yeah
when you finger the one night you got
you got the [__] uh I can see why
like these are terrible plans like the
worst
plan festos oh not
festos the this is the pl so far like
gather a few hundred to get a [__] at
a strip club acquire herpes hide it from
Paula until she this isn't a good idea
none of this seems like a see we lost me
I had a disease for a while I never got
it tested it went away after like four
years it just disappeared oh my God yeah
yeah I used to date this college girl
she was filthy college girls are like
kids in daycare they're filthy filthy
and they got morals like I've never had
sex but I give blow jobs what are you
getting at what are you getting that
what do you mean you you never gave I I
never had sex but I used to blow my
boyfriend in college what are you
talking about what the [__] you you got
morals you know what's funny I I I I
used to have that stance for uh you know
my my first few te years there I I
definitely thought for some reason in my
head like blow [__] doesn't count as
sex um it's its own thing a Catholic um
no no no I I I swear I think it's just
as a child of the 9s like as a result of
of Lewinsky I really do where it's like
oh well this isn't sex that's the com
that that was the thought of myself and
my peers [__] aren't sex I could
suck a dick I'm still a virgin and I
would I would really think like that
where it's like well I don't want to I
don't want to have sex with so and so
but like I would blow them and not think
it was the same it would be nice to just
hang out there was a certain age where
all of a sudden it was like wait a
minute why do I think it matters what
this number like there's going to be
this number of people like I can't pass
a certain number of people I've slept
with why I could and honestly it's
probably safer to [__] someone with a
condom than it is to suck their dick so
what am I what am I doing
morally uh the who gives a [__] but that
was probably like it's however you look
it's however the after after colge I
don't even trust a condom anymore do you
know that I really really yeah I just I
don't know I I got really lucky I was
stupid barely use them like barely
almost never oh my God see in my head I
wasn't getting laid that much so it
wasn't it wasn't like it was a huge
issue but in my head like it it's like
you you I might automatically die like
honestly I might get pregnant immediate
I would be so terrified I always I
always used condoms all the time like
crazy HIV got spread like in 84 when
Rock cuds and stuck and an ' 85 I met a
girl we went on a few
dates and we had sex like one of those
heat to Passion I was young she was
young and then she became my [__]
wife 6 years later so I was with her
till [__] 90 right 91 right so I had
no no diseases and nothing like that and
then I met a girl right away when I
separated they were college girls and I
I ended up sleeping with her and the
roommate and dating both of them and you
know the whole thing yeah yeah and
that's why I knew I had something one of
those two dirty [__] gave me some
from Kansas I didn't know what it was it
was like leakage and itches [__] oh my
God God
no leakage but I wouldn't go to the
doctor [__] that I would rub tuna fish
juice on it and move
on and then I met the stripper God knows
what diseases she had God knows and with
her too the first couple times it was
just fooling around and fingers and
[__] and [__] but then we started
having sex and by that point who cares
about a condom and I remember giving her
a stabbing the first time going I know
I'm going to get something but who am I
you know who gives a [__] I deserve
something look at me I'm an animal oh my
God and I knew I got something from it I
just love how calmly you said fingers
and
[__] when you're doing blow and
champagne but he ho hummed it yeah he
was fingers and [__] you know no the
basics not my [__] in their [__]
when I got coed up I get all evil and
then
um I started comedy and you know those
first from 93 to who knows you know me
and Lee sat outside one night and talked
about stupid escapades I couldn't SLE
sleep after we went home it was you know
you R the [__] road around the
country you know and so today I'm very
lucky you know and I'm not even
good-looking I can't imagine if I was
like a hot feat act slinging dick after
every show I would just bump into
victims getting high you know the
hottest girl will give you a piece of
[__] at 5: in the morning when you're
doing coach I mean it was like once they
go back to the hotel and the friend
leaves and it's you and them it's just a
matter of time before the clothes come
off I don't care how engaged or how
married they are if it's 5 and you still
got two grams of blow I'm running
against the Clocky I'm giving this chick
a stabing she's going to show me a
titties I'm going to jerk off on the
stomach something's going to happen
here oh my God
what do you think Lis say how you
feeling brother I'm feeling okay I'm
what do you got what do you got plans
you got Pismo Beach when are you leaving
uh late tomorrow night so why Pismo
Beach what was how was that decision
formed uh you're going to laugh well I
drove by it it looks really cool looks
really nice but uh we picked it because
I P I picked the hotel because it's
within walking distance to a movie
theater and some places to
eat but it's like right act we're going
to PE Beach but so do you have a Beach
that yeah but are you close to the beach
oh yeah but I I you're not bringing a
bikini and I'll bring it but I it's it's
too cold to go in there you could still
put a blanket on and go to the beach and
get some vitamin D that would help you a
little bit what you what you think what
are you going to do sit in a [__]
movie theater all day like a [__]
Dracula while the sun's out like some
[__] waiting for something to comeing
and shoot you yeah let me go let's go to
the movie theater and see a dumb [__]
movie
why you got sunlight and you're on a
beach I'm just you know I'm just trying
to help you out I'm go to the beach
there's a butterfly thing and there's a
kind ofter PL I don't know there's a
butterfly garden okay that's great 10
tell her to come back when she gets back
that you're ready to rock you eat 10
stars of death you ain't going to see no
butterflies you're part of the death
Association you you don't see you a got
time for butter what what are you
[__] some butterfly dude what else
they got the H Castle I don't know what
are you doing I don't know what they got
there but how' you get talked into that
that's get scratched from the addendum
okay just call the Lor and say listen if
I once I meet Henry the8 then I'll go to
a [__] Castle I'm not going to a
[__] Castle oh my God okay all right
well there's a drive-in movie theater
too yeah there you go at night and we're
going to do that uh sure at night see
that's nice I want you to get some I do
during the day time too you can't go to
driver in the daytime you [__] no I
can go to the other movie theater of the
day I know you
it's a joke how many movies do you need
to see it's a joke go to the beach pick
one worse than the other you have no
idea I love him like a brother but it's
it's all over he's the kiss of death
officially he could [__] step into
[__] there could be four hot restaurants
and one shitty one he'll pick the shitty
one where you get diarrhea and people
bleed from the uterus I've never CAU
food poison no no no no you never got
nothing [__] sucker have you seen what
restaurants they have down there yeah
yeah okay split them up I don't know
what I I don't have memorized you do yes
you do you you already have your menu
planned I know how leis sayat Works who
the [__] do you think you're talking to
no I I know you you listen last night
you stayed in look me in the face [__]
sucking I know you and Paul are got on
the computer two Harvey homos that you
all you sat there and you watched the
restaurants and decided your meals they
have fries carnus look go ahead don't
lie to me close but not not quite lie
don't lie to me no I'm going to be very
honest so yeah and we didn't do it
yesterday but we did go on Yelp and see
what's around the area I tell you cuz
everyone does that Joey not everyone
just goes around this is a Jew that acts
like [__] Johnny white bread all
right and what did yel tell you I I
don't have a memorized let me check but
I know that what restaurants are off the
top of your mind go ahead let me you
want on yel to take the advice from
[__] strangers Len no no no no I'm
just you know me we're just talking it
out here you want I yel to find the
advice from who know when piso Beach sir
you don't need to know nobody you keep
your eyes open you look for a rating you
look at the people serving you don't
want to go to a Chinese restaurant some
Arabs serving you you know I'm saying
you can't have that [__] all right so I
have to do a scouting trip yeah you walk
around you milk it Pismo beats there got
to be somebody selling burritos and
tacos yeah of course all right so but
what the restaurants did you and Paul a
pick see all right but listen to me uh
Vicky you know I love you I know this
[__] like the back of my head he
can't make a move without me being here
I know that she sat him down and him and
her in front of the computer like two
[__] MOS cuz he should know everyone
does this no not everybody not everybody
only people like Chad and and Nathan
those [__] muks would do something
like that can can I just uh chai big cuz
I'm I I I expected him to Google Yelp he
did that too he he actually he pulled up
his own personal Yelp profile where
there is a list of things saved can book
Mark yeah because he already picked all
these out just like you're saying I
didn't pick the menus out though that's
the one thing he's wrong about cuz I
like to be surprised
yeah pick the rest [__] we place in
town and take the word from strangers
I'm just trying to help you out here I'm
just I'm just an organized Jew you can
just yeah you're an organized Jew by
picking out bad restaurants on bad
restaurants and sitting on there all
four plus stars all right read the
restaurants to me all right Fruitland
casad Del saor it's a Mexican place let
me let me go with the big ones actually
Ventana Grill has a th000 reviews four
stars uh steakhouse Gibsons for
545 what else is there uh what are the
oh no that's in that's in Chicago what
are the chances you taking out of Gibson
they even have the B
Chicago that's what the chances you even
having the balls to bring up Gibsons
without getting a back hand she likes
steak she one time we didn't want steak
and she'll he'll never forget it we we
we we want pizza what what are you
talking about I'm giving you a free card
to go to Ruth Chris somebody sent us a
$100 gift certificate to go to Ruth
Chris he go stop over give it a card you
know take it on nice steak show her what
it is to live like a [__]
doctor okay you know he calls me
back we we both wanted Wings and Pizza
no we did not they had pizza they had
pizza there pizza and bad Pizza no not
bad it wasn't even like good pizza it's
bad Pizza I can see if it's like it's
coming from Boston Frozen my mom you
know no no he got pizza they waited
online Pizza Rev no it's not Pizza Rev
you know I'm I'm embarrassed I'm in
[__] embarrassed I tried I tried you
don't know all this [__] you don't think
I know all this [__] I think you're
going to be shocked at the outcome
people look at Yelp dude that's why it's
like a big the biggest website ever
nobody looks at Yelp no one looks at yel
only you look at Yelp and pick
restaurants from Yelp and GrubHub and
you believe strangers who don't know
dick about food nothing they're worse
than you are you that's you why you
start your own Yelp service cuz I didn't
got time to eat a bad restaurants okay I
hear about the best we go in there we
conquer it we leave that's it that's all
the website is two like two lines like
that's all you need just listen to what
I'm telling you sure listen because you
like like what they say to me to when
they like Taking Chances yeah you got to
you got to go for the yeah that's good
yeah that's great go take a chance by
yourself you ended up with Rosco's
Chicken eating the [__] pigeon and
God knows what else you know went up The
Corn 50 yards away he was from stout
I've been Stout times you've never taken
another step now you have you don't have
to gos to take a step you want to go
heat a shitty Burger on lanasham and
[__] V Victory he found the place
that puts big that's a good place yeah
it's a great place yeah people talk
about it all the time I hear people
there a line in front of there right now
where where do you go to talk to people
about restaurants you know me dog I
weigh 300 [__] pounds I run with
professionals if they go somewhere good
they call right away and go dog I know
what you're like go in there and I take
their advice but I would never take the
advice of some [__] dude on Yelp or
GrubHub we're from the East Coast we
know the best we're not going to take
some advice from some [__] I believe
in the goodness of people get the what
goodness of people they're like you they
P they put [__] pork on French fries
like gavones and yeah and then they know
what I like they know what I like and so
yeah you know what you like you're not
going to stop I'm tell he poisoned his
father Paul ate bad shrimp already at
some place they just walk into a Korean
place I have people around me making bad
decisions I'm not making bad decisions
you're the leader of them you the lead
you enhance that they eat dumplings in
shitty places you know it's constant and
I love him to death I love him to death
with all my heart I just want and I knew
didn't I tell you he went online already
of course I did I was just so shocked to
see the profile the best one you've
yelped before I don't write reviews I
have two reviews you don't write thank
God you don't write reviews I don't
write reviews except those God you don't
spread your [__]
lizard
places who you get mad at let me see the
two RS oh my god let's see I think I'm
please read one of these oh sh I have
three reviews one is from Denny's cuz I
was angry at
them
Denny's somebody somebody needs to look
that up on Yelp oh this is cool actually
I I have one really good one to help a
guy out and I have the the zipline guy
that [__] me over who ended up closing
so that was they closed up shop yeah
they ran up they closed shop so that was
good Denny's they took his money on
[__] goon right him and Harvey homo
they
he decides him and his wife decide hold
on we want to be exotic for the weekend
we're going to go
ziplining you know Lee look at Lee that
line will go down it will not go it's
all over you know what I'm saying why
take the chance wait what was the you
would give me a Lee a zipline pass like
that that's like right away you is there
something wrong with you Le a d a deuce
and a half they put them on a little
roope yes you are that tree is going
[__] that tree is going down listen
he listen he he's been telling me for I
haven't gained a pound I know I've
gained like 8 lb I'm on I'm on 250 yes
you you didn't G you didn't gain
no no you didn't oh my God somebody even
told me that they saw Le I didn't
recognize him and [__] they's getting
all Chinese looking again [__] it's all
over they thought he was D Mara with a
haircut that could be the edbl though L
to be fair no no I might have G away but
festos talk to me festos stop [__]
going on yel all right you wrote a
review to the [__] out line and he
called me that morning when cuz listen
I'm the one that bears the brunt of this
ladies and gentlem no you don't you're
thinking you're [__] sitting there
going to leave Joey why are you breaking
his balls you know why cuz I don't
bother nobody I'm sitting there smoking
my reefer I got the cat in one hand I'm
looking at the baby I'm looking at the
wife it's Saturday I'm home and I got a
call from this gos telling me that his
girlfriend bought him group on and
[__] you got to see this [__] you you
can't believe like there's things I hear
hear from him that I really can't
[__] believe like you're living his
negative Yelp reviews no no no oh oh
it's not even Yelp reviews I'm living
bad like listen at his age I was mugging
people and doing blow I was doing prison
time who am I to judge this poor kid but
look at him you don't want to put him on
the zipline he takes one of those poles
down I have zipline many of times no you
have not stop in your backyard when you
82 lbs into the pool so they get the
zipline pass for they 65 bucks him and
his beautiful girlfriend they take an
hour drive they just can't go to a movie
or go find a cat go next time just go to
Van eyes the bushes and look for a cat
that oh no you can't do that you got
poison ivy look for a cat do something
like that no they want to drive an hour
to some [__] line D I'm sitting at
home going this ain't going to work this
kid's going to take down the pole he's
taking down the pole I'm going to get a
call in an hour oh no and by the way I
was at my height of Dave at this point
by the way I was at the height of going
to Dave I was like probably 230 listen
please why you boring me with details
you could take down any rope no but I
I'm not taking down a rope the limit was
250 yeah the limit was 250 he got there
they took one look at Johnny Bananas
here they go listen we can't put him on
oh my God this guy will take down the
[__] pole and then they kept his
money because he put the Hat on or
something like that that's not what
happened what happened they took your
money did they they took our money but
it's because they they have the cheap
system when when I went I don't know if
anyone else has ever done zip lining but
they usually have brakes so but this one
you have to put your hand down and use
hand brakes all right this is this so
what happen you had to do it this so
what happened tell me so I couldn't do
handbrakes in two turns to the level of
expertise that this little [__] high
schooler really like me to so he
canceled me like half the other group so
and they said each time like four people
get sent back so it's not it's not it's
not it's not like a whole bunch of 250
pound chubby Jews going up there there's
regular people they look at you they
look at that little [__] dinosaur
hand on you and they say it's never
going to work he ain't going to be able
to stop it 250 coming at you he's 5'2
coming at you on that rope you know on a
vertical like that I'm no engineering
major but even I if even if I did that
it wouldn't hit you that much cuz he's
more compact I was just he's more
compact he hit you there's a density to
it yeah a density to it he comes down
like a boulder at you and it's all over
that little [__] song and said 250 no
handbrakes no can do you got to go like
John Panet [__] he calls me on the
way home we got thrown out and they kept
our money sure I keep your money for
being stupid that's what happens this
[__] you want zipline you can't walk
around a lake and go fishing you know
right here right in Van L got a fishing
pole
people like that [__] all the time I
can't believe that's what it you don't
write a negative Yelp review about a
zipline place and it's not a great story
no if you look at the place that's what
everyone's complaining about but yeah
cuz they were 250 they oh my
God they're eyeing you up so there isn't
a scale they're eyeing you up no there's
a scale you get on the scale with all
your clothes on and you still have to be
under it so it's not like I can be like
249 like oh I hope no you 250 you my God
I this skill right now list they didn't
throw you out of there cuz you were 238
stop bullsh no I didn't get thrown out
there I just told you I got thrown out
of there you were induce and a half and
the handbrake didn't
work deal with so much worse could have
happened years of college and then and
then I'll get yelled that for not doing
stuff so what am I supposed to do what
not doing stuff you're 28 years old I
call you and you tell me you just watch
eight episod of orange black and red
sure I get agitated there's a thousand
things you could do anything go to the
park but he always picks the bad things
a minor league baseball game two hours
from here surrounded by they almost
stabbed them in the neck no they
didn't it [__] like San
Bernardino I live in the house I can do
a documentary about this Momo every week
is Escapade if it's not Peach no every
week I think last time I was on you you
had just went to a crepe cooking class
oh no no it's it never ends it never
ends it's random yeah random never and I
asked them why you going to gra oh
because I'm we're going to cook grapes
never did I ever get a crepe never have
you did get a crepe and then you m i I
got the crepe that from the night orpe
what was the other cooking class you
went to to learn how to cook steak and
that was good yeah I see how many steaks
I get brought to the [__] office what
was the other class dumpling yeah I can
see how many [__] dumplings you were
going to make here too that one was a
waste of time no [__] all three of them
were a waste of
time plus the trip to bismo plus the
trip to the [__] lion gate up there
what [__] yelping restaurants and I
knew he did that I knew that his
girlfriends sit there and they look at
it together I know that's is what he
does this is unbelievable I'm not trying
to put him down for this I'm trying to
help him out no in America unless you
[__] walk around with a backpack and
you believe in [__] Dungeons and
Dragons nobody sits there with his
girlfriend go let's y restaurants and
see what's in the area this is [__]
crazy cuz it's yeah it's like I never go
to McDonald's and they sell 99 million
Burgers everyone everyone hates on y but
99 992 cuz you don't go there no more
huh 99 to cuz you don't go there no more
I know I used to go there all the time
they miss me they write me letters all
the time they got a new big Mech you
thinking about it
what is it like three three meats what
is it is it just bigger yeah I was never
much I I got into Big Macs at the end
for variety but I was never much of a
big ma person what's the no McDonald's
for just cuz it to [__] bad for you
yeah I miss it though I haven't had
Wendy's in over a year and I'm missing
it's a good one that was your favorite
Wendy's oh yeah you're a lucky dude
brother you're taking care of yourself a
little step by step I know you crave it
I know you'll cave this week weekend and
eat some [__] mili down there in
Pismo Beach you always do dog he go down
there with a plan I could have the best
chef in America come here right now and
go you're going to go to this Taco Stand
you're going to go to this little
breakfast place is not expensive and
you're going to go to this place for
dinner he will [__] all three of those
up he will [__] them up he'll get talked
into Thai food for lunch and and there's
a snake in his soup there's always
something there's always something you
have no idea
every time he tells me he's going on
vacation now I got to worry all weekend
worry I got place in America the no no
no it don't matter it don't matter I
can't wait to hear Monday the rash on
your head it's always something there's
no rash the guy took your money the the
the Crepes there's always something
there's always something my life is
[__] tremendous I have a great life
because I I just sit there he
entertained he doesn't even
know you're down the block from St and
the best pizza around here unless you
have to go back East he ends up in rosos
waffles and chicken never get back in
the [__] car and goes to Raffles
wases and chickens on gawa on Friday
[__] night which I'd rather get shot
in the goddamn [__] head to go on g
on Friday night and I'll tell you why I
don't go to rosos and chicken there I've
been to rosos and chicken it was very
delicious it's a [__] um on whatever
the [__] it is Wilshire it's on Olympic
Pico Pico's rosos and when I went there
I went there with black dudes so I got
treated with respect okay I'm not going
to walk in there with jul Laro over here
and you know that's the last guy they
want to see the black joint a [__]
Jew and a Mexican and a black joint they
gave him the chicken from the [__]
Street they gave the chicken that they
were going to throw out they go give it
to these two [__] muks in here this
little Juju Juju guy just came in here
next time you go to a black place you
got to go in there with a black
personally that's rule number one not a
Mexican black blacker than black afro a
pick in his head that's how you get good
service at a [__] just for the
service that's all that's it cuz now
they can't [__] with you they got to
give you the good [__] you follow me
rule number one or go to Pico rule
number two don't ever go to that [__]
place cuz it's a tight place so while
you're eating chicken you got to smell
Curry I don't [__] with I don't mix both
countries you know what I'm saying I
don't do it I won't do it I've been
invited to eat there they wanted to take
me there for a pitch meeting I refuse to
go in there I don't like the smell of
Curry at no level I don't like Thai food
I don't trust them I'm a Chinese dude
Chinese people are here first I've said
it a thousand times I I ate sushi it
took me 30 years to eat sushi I'm very
happy too I don't eat Vietnamese food I
don't eat Thai food I don't eat no Wong
dong food nothing I run with the Chinese
the Japanese and that's it [__]
everybody else got to stand online and
make me a nice menu I've eaten with the
Filipinos I had the pigeon one time
whatever whatever it's high in protein
what the [__] do I know what would you
do if a if a tie play move next to your
uh uh dry cleaning I would move the [__]
out of there you understand I just don't
like the smell of carry I don't know if
it's Thai I shouldn't insult the Thai
people I'm very sorry I do not like the
smell of any carry whatsoever you
understand me Lisa give me get the
paperwork how many times I got to tell
you CU you're looking around the room so
you're leaving tomorrow night what time
probably around 8:00 thank God how far
is prismal Beach 2 and a half 2 half oh
nice where is this half an hour north of
uh Santa Barbara it's where half an hour
to 40 minutes north of Santa Barbara
okay so it's that way oh very nice look
at you [__] Lee is making progress in
the world I like him I love Lee he's
always having a good [__] time all
right let me tell you something for the
last
month uh why am I lying to you people
for the last three weeks I have been
drinking this hint crisp apple water
infused with crisp apple Apple they sent
me a box it had five different flavors
it had the raspberry you know I don't
remember all the rest of the flavors but
I will tell you something The Taste is
magnificent there's none left in my
refrigerator okay not not
one not
even not even one so we enjoyed them all
right now you should drink eight glasses
of water a day but who really does
coffee soda energy drinks why don't you
just drink more water cuz it's bland you
want something with that tastes good you
ever want to eat a sandwich you can't
eat a sandwich with [__] so soda how
can you eat a [__] uh
moradell with with American cheese and a
piece of salami and some lettuce with
some vinegar and O how you going to
drink that [__] with water but I'll tell
you what with a nice sandwich with a
nice little crisp apple water it's not
that bad that's why you should try hint
water all right hint water was started
by car gold golden a few years ago after
having her four child she was overweight
had terrible acne and overall felt awful
she was drinking 10 diet sodas a day
instead of drinking water because water
is boring but water other options are
there what other options are there
juices full of calories and the no
calorie drinks are garbage that's why
she started hitting water H is pure
water infused with a taste of fresh
fruit that tastes delicious
whether it's the mango peach mango uh
grapefruit or watermelon and many more
it's got no sugar no chemicals just
great tasting all natural fruit flavored
water both health and self magazines
have name hint water the best flavored
water and they know how important
drinking water is to your health all
right so do me a favor you don't have to
carry these cases of water back in the
store you can have them delivered right
to your door what we're going to do is
this right now I'm going to give you a
single variety pack shipped directly to
your door including three bottles of
each of hint four most popular flavors
pineapple watermelon crisp apple and
blackberry it's normally $24 we're going
to do it for $15 at
drinkhint.com
church again I'm going to save you $9
this water is tremendous drinkhint.com
church again that's drinkhint
h.com slur h h i n t drinkhint.com
Church give it a try you save $9 and it
gets shipped directly to your door now
we've talked about this topic before and
we're going to talk about it again the
Hol the holidays are coming you're
sitting there what am I going to get for
this guy what am I going to get for that
guy listen I got the perfect gift for
you right did I tell you that b days are
back oh [__] you is sitting there going
Joey what's a bedday a bedday is this
little [__] thing that snaps on what
I'm selling you is this bedday is a
thing next to your toilet that you sit
on and you put the water temperature and
you sit on and it cleans your muffler
and you wipe it one time with a towel
and you're back in Action you understand
me what we got today is a bedet cost
thousands of dollars but what I got for
is hellotushy.com listen to me they're
portable bed it it's a device that
sprays your butt clean with water like I
said I grew up with a bedday after my
mom died I didn't know how much it meant
to me ever since I've got my hello
tushi.com bday my ass hoes tremendous
right now you understand me thanks to
tushi sleep M day that Clips on to your
existing toilet listen to me it Clips on
to your existing [__] toilet and it
sprays your muffler completely clean
with fresh water think about it you
sitting there you close your eyes you
smoke a joint it's like somebody's
spitting into your [__] you could
take this anywhere you understand me who
needs cowon who needs Jillian barbarry
with a [__] that thing she's selling
that [__] uh the the the the [__]
what do you call elliptical machine
where you can press on a screen and you
could be running through Australia [__]
you I got a portable Beday [__] that W
is hitting your ass hole you just close
your eyes and next thing you know you're
a genie Jack you're floating you
understand me and I'll tell you what
it's tremendous for you it Clips on the
existing toilet and it sprays your
muffler clean with nice water so you're
not sitting on bacteria which causes
hemorrhoids yeast infections and just
plain old rotten ass all right but days
are better for the environment because
they they they there's no [__] paper
so if there's no toilet paper they save
trees all right it takes one pint of
water to wash your muffler think about
it
listen tushi stands behind that product
with a 60-day guarantee and the most
guarantee they'll give you is you're
going to enjoy it like I said you're
sitting there going what am I going to
get my sister for Christmas what am I
going to get my uncle for Christmas both
of them got fat asses sit there next
time you're at a party stare at their
pants look at their ass and
imagine what that [__] Muffler smells
like you ever have one of those ants
that comes over and you like us always
gives you $20 in Christmas but you know
her [__] [__] stinks she's on
disability she eats peanut butter all
day she don't exercise she don't drink
water give that [__] hello tushi.com
for Christmas it makes a terrific
stocking stuffer do you understand me
[__] do you think I'd be here
telling you this this is the best
Christmas gift you can give anybody they
will [__] send you [__] every year
Joey thank you you sent me you saved my
life I'm not bored anymore I'm not on
social
media I'm not hanging out with my
friends I don't go bowling no more what
do you do I just take shits and sit on
the toilet for an hour after that and
spray hot water in my ass and dream of
exotic locals thank you for saving my
life I've already had three people that
have brought me [__] boxes of hello
doui to the shows taking pictures and
said Joey you've changed my life you're
like Joel ostein you're like the the Bay
will change your life all right I don't
give a [__] what you do for the holidays
this is the best give you can give
somebody go to hellotushy.com right now/
Church spell it Lee CH H Ur CH boom and
get 10% off your order delivered to your
door all right you know I love you
[__] with all my heart also like
I ask you always you know I love you
[__] do me a favor December 8th
my special comes up I need for you to
download my special it's cv.com they've
got other entertainment great Comedy
Channel they're [__] tremendous I
need your help I need for you to go to
cv.com what is it it's I think I think
it's just ces.com but ces.com and
pressing Joey bam you're going to get
two months to description for free it's
usually 398 389 398 don't matter it's
[__]
Grace so if you're going on there now
you got Stan hope and I come on December
8th and I promise you you're going to
love the [__] new special all right
do me this favor even if you just get it
and watch the first [__] 10 minutes
you make me [__] happy all right I
don't ask you for much I ask you for
donations do I ask you for [__]
episode money do no you know we're tight
you and I are [__] tight you you're
my people so do me that favor all right
ceso here Lee it's right on [__] here
right yeah say cuz yeah yeah call out
specific all right what I'm going to do
is right now my listeners can try SEO
for free two months when you use the
promo word Joey so go to ces.com right
now and sign up for two months free with
the promo word Joey at check out all
right do me this favor they got great
they got great shows on there Chelsea
petti special kumanji Nani Ron funes
they got Paul F Tomkins on there I mean
listen it's a great channel do me the
solid again I want to thank my girl
Vicky mother [__] peasant for coming
in I also want to thank uh hint water I
want to thank hello tushi.com you know I
love you I want to thank ciso for
putting my special on again ceso the
code word is Joey and as always listen
if it wasn't for Alpha Brain I couldn't
do a [__] podcast on Monday they take
the jet lag right away you know who
takes Camy during the week uh hemp Force
Protein that's what takes care of me you
don't have to believe me give it a shot
go to honor.com and press in church boom
ch ch and get 10% off The Vig delivered
to your door one of the best products
out there the Alpha Brain don't work you
get 100% money back guarantee again I
want to thank hint waterer I want to
thank hellotushy.com I want to thank on
it and I want to thank my people over at
ceso for taking care of me and I want to
take care take care of you by giving you
the free special all right I want to
thank Vicky pezza looking beautiful with
her long hair do for the wedding and I
want to thank my man lee who is stoned
to the Gil again again he's sitting
there not even knowing what [__]
planet he is but you know what he's my
brother Lee he don't need know what
planet he is who gives a [__] what are
you going to say like
I no I know everybody just sits up and
looks up at the sty and [__] uh
that's one time he came back with a sty
one time he went on vacation he came
back with two sty one in each ey and
then it wouldn't go away it would come
back it kept coming back his grandmother
his mother-in-law wanted to burn candles
in his eyes like Mexican witchcraft he
wouldn't let it she told him and the sty
came back cuz he's the [__] you know
this where I live with ladies and
gentlemen 4 years of Emerson I try to
help him but he he's on yel getting
suggestions she wanted to burn jalapenos
and put that on my eyelids so that's
even crazier yeah but it gets rid of the
sty it lasted him a month he walked
around like somebody poked him in the
eye he had little hemorrhoids sticking
out of his eye it didn't squirt it
always happens right before I see him
like like it can it canot happen like it
happened once and Vegas with him I've
I've lived for 28 years never once had a
diey I think I'm going to be stress
induced now's Pismo beat something dumb
is going to happen they're going to run
a bicycle I've already in the in the C
case of this podcast gotten at least one
food recommendation for Pismo Beach okay
as long as so believe them before you
believe yel and you'd make me happy
what's the food recommendation let's see
is it a hummus joint no I don't think I
think I think it's a fish joint cuz it's
a lot of seafood up there there you go
there you go but you don't eat fish
because I I I I eat shrimp it's got
nucleus in it and splash Cafe oh [__]
what what kind of fish do you eat Lee
you e a nice piece of halet with some
french fries maybe if I'm going to eat
fish I like hit's okay cuz it really
doesn't really taste like much swordfish
is pretty
good if they marinate it well well I
wish you have a nice time you deserve it
you wor hard last we with your Uncle
Joey it's for her it's for her cuz she
what are the results Friday so the the
bad news or the good news is Friday yeah
she's going to get good news oh she'll
be F be fun oh cool yeah they have they
have chowder they have uh shrimp and
chips sh listen to me Vicky peza he will
not eat that I will Doo e here he will
not eat that guaranteed gar [__] te
he'll walk right past it the boss will
say I don't want to go there I don't the
boss Monday morning I'm checking in yeah
he won't eat that I'm going to Tweet I'm
going to Tweet a meal from him that
Splash he'll go by himself he'll [__]
give her a Cosby pill and when she's
sleeping he'll run over there eat and
run back oh honey you must have passed
out it must have been the sun he won't
go over there little it's good looks he
walk in front of look at the menu and
she'll go little festos we can't eat
him I'm throw you off the pier here and
then he's going invite you here for my
wedding and throw you off the P I ain't
going to your [__] wedding [__] suck
you I'm going be like I'm going to be
like [__] Vicky pezes I'm going to
tell you yeah yeah yeah in the last
minute tell you f not my thing yeah it's
too [__] far go [__] yourself I'm
going to sit there with Jews and
Mexicans I would never do something like
that I would never do something like
that I get shot in the [__] head they
would come right from Israel and shoot
me right in the [__] head who's that
it's like a Nazi movie Jews in Israel
and Mexicans sitting in one room
room what do you think what do you think
is going to happen what do you think is
going to happen somebody in your family
is going to get
stabbed that's what's going to happen
some Raider cousin's going to come in
you're going to put on [__] ice cube
he wants iced tea and next thing you
know there's a Jew bleeding in the room
that's all you [__] need you know
what I'm saying oh my God it is going to
be pretty funny to see that all right
good keep keep [__] fantasizing [__]
that's what he wants he wants damage and
[__] just just let him move I don't want
to fight just let him move in for now
just get there takes you 10 11 years to
get it together you really don't want a
roommate anyway watch he's going to
throw her out within 6 months he'll
throw her out once football season she
starts [__] with his world this
little dude likes to be alone he don't
get it but he's a [__] jav homo he
invites her to move in move in he
doesn't know the mistake he talked
himself into this is a kid that since
I've lived with him hasn't had a
roommate have a great weekend guys thank
you very much we'll be back Sunday night
you'll have a podcast Monday morning
listen like I said this [__] Friday
Houston Texas but next Wednesday the
Irvine Improv the night before
Thanksgiving 8:00 myself Steve Stone and
Lee aatt will be there I love you guys
have a great weekend stay
black that was a oh my God hilarious oh
my God my face hurt
Yelp I was like
SM
somewhere in hotel room guys start
realize that Eternal turn into off it's
[Music]
a.m. 2 a it's 2
a.m. yeah s on the loose sirens my head
wrapped up in silence all circuit to
death can I be cold my whole
[Music]
life is in that house feel like being
home the
star go now that I fall too far you
know when the bullet
theone you
[Music]
come falling down a spiral Destination
Unknown double cross messenger all alone
can't get no connection can't get
through where are
you
well the night with heav on his guil
mind this far from the
B when the H man comes he knows damn
well he has been
chea
[Music]
he the
Twilight this is the feel
my my be move the mo St
[Music]
you so
you when
the
[Music]
when
w
[Music]
this this is a man house is not being
blown my M the Moon Star where am I to
go now that I Fall to
far
tolight
[Music]
home
like
[Music]
my that
I
you when theet hits the
phone you will come to
know
the when the
[Music]
B